Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Pog.
Massive Pog.
Wobei ich weiß gar nicht, was so Pog ist.
Chat-Kontroll ist definitiv nicht Pog.
Aber da will ich gar nichts zu sagen.
Hör mal bloß auf.
Das reg ich mich wieder auf, wenn ich dazu jetzt was sagen muss.
Er gibt immer noch keine neuen Emotes.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ich müsste mal fragen.
Die mir die alten Emotes hier gemacht hat.
Ob die noch Emotes macht.
Weil.
Die kommen aus der Ukraine.
Und da gibt es ja gerade andere Probleme.
Als Emotes gestalten.
Also vielleicht macht die gar keine Emotes gerade.
Schauen.
Wäre schon nice.
Wenn die gleich hier die Emotes machen könnte.
Weil.
Dann würden die konsistent aussehen.
Oh, ich muss meine Pilzsauce noch nehmen.
Sekunde.
Moment, wo ist mein Tee?
So, jetzt.
Da bin ich wieder.
Ich würde sagen,
bis das Streamrichter angelaufen ist,
machen wir das, was wir am Anfang des Streams immer machen müssen.
Mini-PC starten.
Und Screen.
35 Streamstreak.
Alter.
Bist aber auch immer da, oder?
Excellent.
Das ist...
Ja.
Quasi.
So oft wie ich streame.
Also nicht oft.
Ist das irgendwie vier Monate oder so am Stück.
Jeden Stream da.
Aber exzellent.
Dann musst du warten, bis deine Katz will.
Sonst keine Chance.
Meine Katz war schon zwei Tage nicht mehr da.
Wobei das nicht stimmt.
Das ist gar nicht meine Katz.
Das habe ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Die kommt mich ja nur besuchen hier.
Die hier, guckt, warte mal.
Die da.
Die hier.
Die kommt mich ja nur besuchen.
Das ist nicht meine Katz.
Die kommt immer nur einmal am Tag normalerweise vorbei.
Und die war jetzt schon zwei Tage nicht mehr da.
Jetzt mache ich mir fast schon Gedanken, wo die ist.
Hat das Twitter behauptet?
Hab ich gar nicht gelesen.
Moin.
Was ist das eigentlich?
Cry.
Kriegt man dann diese Badge?
Ach so, das meinst du.
Ja, ja.
Ja, die Leute auf Twitter, beziehungsweise xformally known as Twitter, die schreiben viel Scheiße, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Da ist ja Twitter schon bekannt für, beziehungsweise, das heißt Twitter ist dafür bekannt.
So gut wie jedes Social Media ist dafür bekannt, dass die Leute viel Scheiße schreiben.
Ich glaube aber, ohne Scheiß, ich glaube das cringigste, was es gibt, ist LinkedIn.
Also, das ist teilweise so unglaublich dumm.
Ich lese das ja nicht.
Also, ich lese keine LinkedIn-Posts.
Ich lese LinkedIn-Posts nur, wenn irgendjemand auf Reddit mal wieder einen besonders dämlichen LinkedIn-Post postet.
Und die sind meistens so dämlich, dass ich davon ausgehe, dass viele der normalen Posts auch super dämlich sind.
wenn schon quasi diese Grad von Dämlichkeit nur auf Reddit schafft.
Aber auf LinkedIn erzählen die dir ja auch, warum quasi mit 40 Grad Fieber trotzdem arbeiten quasi das Beste ist.
Und wisst ihr, welche Formulierung ich da immer bei den Amis ganz schlimm finde, wenn die dann schreiben, take responsibility oder sowas.
Ja, geil.
Voll krasse Responsibility, bei 40 Grad noch zu arbeiten.
Moment.
Listening.
Ich meine nicht 40 Grad.
Das war jetzt missverständlich.
Ich meine nicht 40 Grad
Außentemperatur. Ich meine 40 Grad Fieber.
Dass die bei 40 Grad Außentemperatur bei den Amis noch arbeiten, das kann ich verstehen.
Die haben ja alle eine Klimaanlage.
Was wir über kurz oder lang wahrscheinlich auch alle brauchen.
Ich habe schon eine. Auf der Arbeit haben wir auch welche.
Ah, yes. Wir haben erst gestern geupdatet.
Natürlich gibt es heute noch mehr Updates.
Exzellent.
Da werden wir nicht drum herum kommen.
Klimaanlagen-Stelz.
Tust du Solaranlagen haben?
Nee. Ich habe mich damit nur am Rande beschäftigt bisher, weil bei mir gibt es keine Möglichkeit, außer direkt aufs Dach.
Also ich kann jetzt auch nicht erstmal so ein bisschen zum Austesten Balkonkraftwerk oder so dranhängen.
Ich habe nichts, wo man das gescheit hinstellen könnte.
Und ich habe keinen Bock, 30.000 Euro auszugeben, um Oma zu gucken.
Ja, da sind aber Bäume
Das ist gar nicht so einfach
Ja, ich hab nen Stall, ja
Aber da sind Bäume
Und das glaubt nicht, dass das gut funktioniert
Warum mach ich CacheOS anstelle von Vanilla Arch?
Weil
Weil ich den CacheOS Hype mal nachfühlen wollte
Das war ja eine Zeit lang mega gehypt.
Und ich muss sagen, ich finde es gar nicht schlecht.
Letztendlich ist es ja eine Art,
die Loks nur mit ordentlich vorkonfiguriertem KDE
und vorkonfigurierten Snapshots und sowas.
Ja, vom Garten müsstest du dann irgendwie
ein Stromkabel wieder zurückführen.
Das ist auch doof.
So.
Und das ist ganz gut vorkonfiguriert.
Cash US.
Deswegen bleibe ich dabei.
Ich mag auch KDE, muss ich sagen.
Ihr wisst ja, ich habe die ganze Zeit immer einen Tiling Window Manager benutzt.
Also ich hatte ja bisher...
Guck mal.
Ich kann euch das jetzt mal im Vergleich zeigen.
Also die ganze Zeit habe ich ja jahrelang hier ein nackiges Arch benutzt mit I3.
Also das war noch X.
X.org mit I3.
Und wenn das dann irgendwann mal gestartet ist.
drei Stunden später gestartet ist, dann
muss ich noch einen Bug fixen, den Windows 11
und vor allem bei Workstation 26 haben.
Und jetzt sollte es eigentlich funktionieren.
Genau, guck, also im Prinzip
ist es für mich gar kein großer Unterschied,
weil ich habe es bisher immer so gehabt,
auf meinem
Nackischen Arch mit i3, ja.
Okay, geil.
Also hier auf dem ersten Tab Fullscreen Firefox, auf dem zweiten Tab Fullscreen Terminal.
Max, wirst du jetzt eigentlich schon beim Autofahren gefilmt?
Ne, wie kommst du da drauf?
Du meinst, ob ich ein Dashcam habe, oder was?
Oder was meinst du?
Zumindest
habe ich irgendwelche News verpasst.
Die News habe ich noch nicht mitbekommen, ja.
Kamera EU-Überwachung, Faktencheck, okay.
Okay, das gucken wir uns gleich an.
GitHub-Search, guck mal.
So, zumindest aktuell habe ich das halt
die ganze Zeit so gehabt in der VM hier.
Ne, Firefox, Terminal,
hier im Zweifelsfall mehrere Terminals,
hier in den Editor, IDE, was auch immer,
auf so und das war es mehr oder weniger.
Also ich habe eh schon relativ selten Gebrauch gemacht hier von Tiling Window Manager Features, weil die Anwendung, wo ich Tiling am meisten brauche, ist das Terminal.
Browser mache ich einfach Tabs auf.
So, das Terminal ist eigentlich das, wo ich Tiling am meisten brauche.
Das Ding ist nur, ich benutze im Terminal ja auch gar nicht quasi das Tiling vom OS, sondern ich benutze das Tiling, falls man es so nennen kann, vom Terminal.
Deswegen brauche ich eigentlich nur ein Terminal hier im Fullscreen und gut ist.
So, und bei KDE, machen wir das mal wieder aus, so war das die ganze Zeit.
Und bei meinem KDE ist es im Prinzip genauso.
Erster Desktop, Browser im Fullscreen, zweiter Desktop, Terminal im Fullscreen.
Hier kann ich teilen, wie ich lustig bin.
Hier müssen wir Chatterino anmachen.
Und auf dem dritten Desktop IDE Editor oder halt auf dem dritten Desktop IDE, auf dem
dritten Desktop Visual Studio Code und Browser.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Ja?
Also ganz easy.
Und deswegen ist es für mich so gut wie keine Umgewöhnung gewesen zwischen Tiling
Window Manager und i3.
Äh, zwischen i3, Tiling Window Manager und KDE.
Dafür habe ich bei KDE viele neue geile Features, nämlich das allerwichtigste, guck mal hier,
Wobbly Windows.
Ist das nicht schön, wie weich und flüssig das ist?
Wobei ihr seht es gar nicht so weich und flüssig, weil ihr es nur mit 48 FPS seht.
Ich sehe es mit 240 FPS.
Das ist nicht nice.
Kann GLX Gears, geht GLX Gears eigentlich auf Wayland?
240 FPS, Leute.
Werden meine Fenster gerendert.
Und guck mal.
Sogar die Gears können wobbeln.
Ist das nicht nice?
So, gut.
Also, was meinte ihr?
Sollte ich mich erinnern?
ZDF?
Hammerabpflicht.
überwacht die EU jetzt alle Autofahrer.
Alter, die gehen mir auf den Sack.
Die können sich alle mal verpissen mit ihrem Scheiß.
Neuwagen in der EU müssen nun eine Kamera an Bord haben,
die prüfen, ob der Fahrer am Steuer abgelenkt ist.
Manche wird dann den...
Ja, das ist ja auch auf allen Kanälen
und auf allen Ecken und Enden zu erkennen,
dass sich das in die Richtung entwickelt.
Ich finde es immer...
Jetzt muss ich doch von Chat-Kontrolle anfangen.
Eigentlich habe ich keinen Bock auf Chatkontrolle, weil dann reg ich mich auf.
Naja, zumindest die Zeichen sind ja klar die letzten Jahre, über das es in die Richtung geht.
Und was ich immer geil finde, wir spielen uns so auf der Welt immer super moralisch auf,
dass wir so den krassen moralischen Highground haben.
Und im Prinzip machen wir Überwachungskram, wie wir sonst das kritisieren bei den China-Chinesen
oder in Russland oder in sonstigen anderen Ländern.
Aber wir machen dann das gleiche.
Aber bei uns, bei uns ist die Überwachungssache ja nur zum Besten von allem.
Und zum Schutz der Kinder und so.
Das ist übrigens, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch da mal drüber in Gedanken gemacht habt.
Das ist aber einfach ein krasser Trick.
Es ist zum Schutz der Kinder.
Es geht dort keinem.
Also wenn das wirklich zum Schutz der Kinder wäre.
Ja.
Wenn die wirklich was zum Schutz der Kinder machen würden.
Da könnte man sich ja tatsächlich überlegen, okay, warum nicht, ja? Kann ja eigentlich keiner was dagegen haben. Aber die machen das nicht zum Schutz der Kinder. Denen ist der Schutz der Kinder vollkommen egal. Das ist einfach nur vorgeschoben. Das ist ein Trick, damit man sagen kann, da kannst du quasi, das war ich gerade gesagt, da kannst du quasi gar nicht dagegen sein.
Weil wenn du dich öffentlich hinstellst und sagst, ich bin gegen den Schutz der Kinder, da gucken dich natürlich alle schepp an, zu Recht auch.
Aber dadurch kannst du das halt nicht richtig aushebeln.
Deswegen musst du sagen, wie es ist, das ist komplett vorgeschoben, um eben sich in die Richtung hier zu entwickeln.
Den geht der Schutz der Kinder am Arsch vorbei
Was da immer vorgeht, also hier jetzt nicht
Aber das ist, wie gesagt
Das werden wir in nächster Zeit
Immer noch öfters sehen
Nachdem sie jetzt ja schon mit Trick 17
Die Chatkontrolle durchgedrückt haben
By the way
Was ich übrigens ganz witzig finde
Wenn wir es jetzt schon haben, scheiß drauf
Wenn wir es jetzt schon haben, kann ich mich mal kurz drüber aufregen
Äh, Nitta
Ich glaube, da Spahn hatte ja ein Video gepostet.
Oder nee, es wurde ja ein Video vom Spahn gepostet.
Warte mal, ich muss mal hier auf Nitter, dass ich ordentlich Twitter suchen kann.
Da gab es doch ein Video vom Spahn.
So, genau, hier, guck mal.
Pass mal auf.
Ich lasse mal die Musik zur Entspannung, weil ansonsten dreht man da durch.
Pass mal auf, was er sagt.
Wir als CDU, CSU, Bundestagsfraktion sind gegen die anlasslose Kontrolle von Chats. Das wäre so, als würde man vorsorglich mal alle Briefe öffnen und schauen, ob da etwas Verbotenes drin ist. Das geht nicht, das wird es mit uns nicht geben.
So, ratet mal, wer geschlossen für die Chatkontrolle gestimmt hat.
Da kommt ihr nie drauf.
Also falls ihr mir das nicht glaubt, Moment.
Abstimmung, Chat-Kontrolle nach Parteien.
Da gab es doch so einen schönen...
Ey, da könnte ich mich auch drüber aufregen.
Es hat ja bei der Tagesschau keiner da gescheit drüber berichtet, ne?
Und wisst ihr, was ich daran besonders schlimm finde?
Ich habe ja eh schon so ein bisschen Skepsis immer gegen,
sagen wir mal so, wie unabhängig da berichtet wird.
Nennen wir es mal so.
Und ich habe mir schon im Vorfeld gedacht, mal gucken, ob die Tagesschau darüber berichtet.
Und die haben zwar darüber berichtet, aber wie?
Komplett lächerlich.
So nach dem Motto, ja, das hat eine kleine Hürde genommen.
Und dann haben sie irgendwas geschrieben, ja, ganz, wie haben sie es ausgedrückt?
Eine, wir müssen uns gleich mal angucken.
Zumindest...
Hier gab es doch irgendwo...
Hier.
Äh...
Ich finde jetzt das Bild nicht.
Gab es auf Twitter?
Gab es jede Menge?
Hat jemand?
Vielleicht hat das ZDF sinnvoll was dazu geschrieben.
Die haben natürlich auch nicht gezeigt, wie abgestimmt hat.
Das wäre natürlich noch mal geiler gewesen.
Ja, genau.
Guck mal, sogar die FDP.
Ja, den brauche ich jetzt auch nicht.
Wo ist denn das Bild, Mann?
Okay, wir gehen mal auf Nitta.
und suchen mal
Chatkontrolle
CDU.
Hier.
Die haben geschlossen,
die haben geschlossen,
gestimmt,
dass sie die Chatkontrolle
weiter haben wollen.
Und vorher in dem Video hat er ganz klar gesagt, mit uns nicht, by the way, das ist E-Trick 17 gewesen, die Abstimmung war nicht, wir stimmen darüber ab, dass die Chatkontrolle weitergeführt wird, die Abstimmung war, und jetzt kommt der Witz da dran, die Abstimmung war, dass die Chatkontrolle, also man sollte quasi abstimmen, dass die Chatkontrolle nicht kommt.
Also die haben das quasi negated, dass es schwieriger wird, dagegen zu stimmen.
Also die haben uns hardcore verarscht.
Also ich meine, guck mal hier.
30 von 30 haben gestimmt, sie wollen weiter Chatkontrolle haben.
Wir als CDU, das wird es mit uns nicht geben.
Das geht nicht, das wird es mit uns nicht geben.
Das wird es mit uns nicht geben?
Wortwörtlich?
30 sagen, ja, wollen wir.
Das können ja doch keine mehr erklären, Alter.
Das können ja doch wirklich keine mehr erklären.
Aber letztendlich glaube ich mittlerweile,
die sind da schon drüber raus,
die wissen, dass sie unbeliebt as fuck sind
und sie keiner mehr haben will.
Und
da kann man auch einfach weitermachen,
weil es ist eh egal.
Ah ja.
Der F-Broker macht, ich war schon öfters mal in Zeitungen und im Fernsehen.
Ich habe einfach die Erfahrung gemacht, dass Journalisten inkompetent sind und nicht böse.
Da wird so inkompetent zusammengefasst und geschehen.
Ja, ich kann mir das durchaus auch vorstellen, dass das oftmals gar keine böse Absicht ist.
Aber man dürfte nicht vergessen, das ist denen ihr Job.
Die machen dann quasi nicht, wofür sie da sind im Endeffekt.
Und gerade die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, die immer erzählen so nach dem Motto, sie sind quasi alternativlos, ohne sie geht gar nichts, weil sie sind so super krass korrekt und unabhängig und ordnen immer alles schön ein für uns und sonst was.
Dass die dann nicht in der Lage sind, da wirklich mal drüber zu berichten, wie es auch ist.
Weil wenn man sich mal diesen Artikel hier drüber durchliest, ne, Scannerlaubnis nimmt Hürde im EU-Parlament.
Dass da wirklich hardcore mit unsauberen Mitteln getrickst wurde, wird in keinem Abschnitt erwähnt.
Was auch nicht erwähnt wird, das was ich euch hier gerade gezeigt habe, und das ist ja nichts Geheimes, ja,
dass die CDU ganz klar gesagt hat, mit uns nicht und sie haben geschlossen dafür gestimmt.
Sie sagen vorher, nein, mit uns definitiv nicht und dann sagen sie, ja doch.
Und ansonsten wird das hier überhaupt nicht irgendwie,
ja, dass es den jahrelangen Streit gibt, das ist schon,
aber das wird überhaupt nicht zum Verfahren und wie da getrickst wurde, das ist total oberflächlich.
Und ich meine, dafür sind die da
Das finde ich halt mal richtig kacke
Ganz schwach
Genau
Noch nie
Aber wisst ihr, was das geile ist?
Mittlerweile sind wir an einem Punkt
Ja, so nach dem Motto
Überwachung überall, aber bitte nicht
Bei Politikern und wenn einer dann ein bisschen
ein bisschen forsch ist, auf Twitter
oder so, dann, äh, da kommt
gleich die Polizei heim, äh, mit, mit
Hausdurchsuchung und Anzeige
und allem, weil irgendjemand geschrieben
hat, äh,
Lügensternchensternchen auf Twitter.
Genau. Lügen darf man nicht
sagen. Das ist ganz, ganz böse.
Wie war das?
Er hat nicht gelogen, er hat die Unwahrheit gesagt.
Kannst du halt nicht auch mal irgendwas...
Das kannst du halt komplett, komplett,
komplett vergessen, ne?
Und wisst ihr, was ich halt auch geil finde?
Also, in den letzten paar Jahren kam immer wieder bei fast jedem Thema, was ein bisschen kontrovers war, kam, oh nein, das gefährdet unsere Demokratie, das untergräbt unsere Demokratie und bla.
Und ja, das war auch teilweise sicherlich so in der Richtung.
Aber jetzt, wo das quasi fast noch nie dagewesene Art und Weise,
wie wir in dieser Richtung verarscht wurden, kommt in der Richtung nichts.
Du kannst doch nicht sagen, wir stimmen dreimal ab, bis das Ergebnis stimmt.
Also wenn das nicht die Demokratie untergibt, dann untergibt es nichts.
Also ich finde das wirklich komplett, komplett, äh, weiß nicht, fällt da gar kein Wort zu ein, ne?
Weil das ist wirklich schädlich aus meiner Sicht.
Und übrigens, wir dürfen jetzt mal, ich habe jetzt ja noch gar nichts zur Chat-Kontrolle selbst gesagt,
jetzt passt du mal auf, stell euch mal vor, das Ganze wird noch ausgeweitet,
was ja übrigens schon, was ja schon diskutiert wird, ne, das ist ja jetzt ja nix,
das ist ja keine, keine Verschwörungstheorie oder sowas,
es wird ja schon so ein bisschen hinter vorgehaltener Hand diskutiert,
dass es auch Chatkontrolle 2.0 geben soll, mit unter anderem kleinseitigen Scans.
Das heißt, die Anbieter können dann, oder vielleicht müssen dann auch, muss man mal gucken, eure Geräte durchsuchen.
Natürlich erstmal nur zum Schutz der Kinder, nach irgendwelchen Darstellungen, wo man nackige Kinder sieht.
Was passiert denn, wenn zum Beispiel Leute im Familienurlaub ihre Kinder fotografiert haben?
Was passiert denn dann?
Das wird eine Flut von False Positive Meldungen geben
Da muss dann wirklich
Die Polizei oder irgendwelche Leute
Ermitteln gegen Oma Erna oder was
Die ihre Enkel im Urlaub fotografiert hat
Also da kommt natürlich dann
Ja aber da gibt es ja noch menschliche Kontrollen
Und sonst was
Alleine schon die Vorstellung
Vorstellung, dass
das dann in irgendeiner Art und Weise jemand
wirklich überprüfen muss,
ob das okay ist, dass die Oma
ihre Enkel fotografiert. Ja, das
wird eine Flut von false positives
geben, das kann ich euch sagen. Es wird auch
und das wird nicht, das wird vorkommen,
ja. Die sind ja alle nicht
die sind ja alle nicht
fehleranfällig. Selbst wenn man mal sagt,
selbst wenn plus in 1% der Fällen
Fehler passieren, ja und wenn
einer den ganzen Tag nichts anderes machen muss, als sich so einen Scheiß
angucken, werden Fehler passieren.
Ähm, ja, das habe ich auch schon mal irgendwann gelesen.
Das hat die aber auch taktisch ungeschickt gemacht, so was weiter zu schicken, falls das das ist.
Ähm, selbst wenn die Leute nur zu 1% einen Fehler machen, ja,
selbst wenn es nur, sagen wir mal so, 1% Fehlerquote bei den Leuten, die das manuell checken
und dann vielleicht nur 1% Fehlerquote bei der Polizei oder was auch immer,
es wird dazu kommen, das ist so sicher wie das Armen in der Kirche,
dass es bei Oma Erna früher oder später eine Hausdurchsuchung gibt wegen Kinderpornos.
Wenn es Chatkontrolle 2.0 gibt.
Falls positiv.
Also sprich, die Oma hat auf einem Urlaub ihre Enkel fotografiert.
Vollkommen normal, legit, überhaupt nichts Schlimmes, Anstößiges.
Das wird erkannt per KI auf dem Gerät von der Oma.
Geht an irgendeinen Überprüfungstyp, der sich den ganzen Tag nichts anderes anguckt,
keinen Bock mehr hat, der sagt jawohl,
ist auch ganz
böse, dann geht es zur Polizei,
der bei der Polizei hat so viel zu tun,
kein Bock, guckt sich nicht richtig an, sagt ja doch,
wird auch sowas sein und dann steht die Polizei
bei der Oma vor der Tür, weil die im Urlaub
ihre Enkel fotografiert hat. Das wird,
das ist so sicher wie das Abend in der Kirche,
es gibt immer eine Fehlerquote,
das wird passieren,
hundertprozentig.
Die Frage ist nur wann.
Ja, also allein
schon solche Dinge. Da sieht man mal, wie
dämlich das ist.
Und dann kommt
ja der nächste, da kommt ja der nächste
Gag bei der ganzen Sache.
Wenn das dann erstmal da ist. Wie gesagt, ich habe ja gesagt,
das ist ein Trick. Weil man kann ja nicht wirklich
dagegen sein, wenn jemand sagt,
man möchte was zum Schutz der Kinder tun. Dann kann man
auch nicht dagegen sein. Es sei denn, man steht
selbst auf sowas.
Dann vielleicht, dass die Leute
dagegen sind. Aber eigentlich kann man nicht
wirklich dagegen sein. Aber das ist ein Trick.
Das ist ein Trick, damit niemand sagen
kann, wir sind dagegen.
Deswegen wird das ja auch immer so verkauft. Deswegen wird nicht
gesagt, wir wollen alle Leute
überwachen und ihre Geräte durchsuchen.
Nein, diese Dinger heißen dann,
was weiß ich, Antrag
zum Schutz der Kinder oder sowas.
Dass dann keiner sagen kann, nee, da sind wir
dagegen. Und wenn einer doch sagt,
ja, da bin ich dagegen, dann
kommt gleich, ja, wie öffentlich,
wird dann gesagt, wie kannst du denn dagegen sein? Das ist ja ganz böse.
Also das ist ein Trick, dass das
gesagt wird. So, und der nächste
Witz ist, der nächste Gag
kommt dann, wenn das
da ist, und das ist
meiner Meinung nach auch
so sicher wie das Arm in der Kirche,
wird das ausgeweitet,
wenn das da ist. Da
kommen dann so Sachen wie Verschlüsselung
soll aufgebrochen
werden. Gut, wenn kleinseitig gescannt wird,
ist das wahrscheinlich eh teilweise gar nicht so
wirklich mehr möglich.
Aber das wird als nächstes,
Als nächstes kommt Verschlüsselung, soll aufgebrochen werden, VPNs sollen verboten werden und solche Geschichten.
Das wird dann vielleicht ein bisschen anders verkauft, ja.
Das wird dann auch verkauft wie verschlüsselte Verbindungen, irgendwie scannen zum Schutz der Kinder,
Verschlüssel der Verbindungen oder irgendwie sowas wird das dann heißen.
Und dann, bam, hast du es am Start, das ist das Nächste.
Dann kommt noch Klarnamenpflicht.
Ja, das ist ja auch, schwirrt ja auch in den Köpfen da der Leute rum, Klarnamenpflicht. Und dann wird das Ganze, wenn wir den Scheiß haben, ja, und das wird dann alles zum Schutz der Kinder gemacht.
Vielleicht, vielleicht wird auch gesagt, zum Schutz der Kinder vor Terroristen. Terroristen ist auch immer ein beliebtes Thema dabei, also zum Schutz der Kinder.
es wird gegen Terroristen gemacht
oder, ja, was gibt es denn sonst noch
was gibt es denn sonst noch so für Dinger
halt so ganz schlimme Sachen, wo keiner was dagegen
sagen kann im Endeffekt
und dann kommt der nächste
wie gesagt, dann kommt der nächste Gag
wenn das dann alles erstmal da ist
dann wird das ausgeweitet
ja
dann kommt als nächstes, ja
wir wollen das ja auch gegen Terroristen machen
und ah, man könnte das ja auch
gegen
für
Mord und Totschlag einsetzen.
So, und dann wird das immer weiter
aufgeweicht, bis wir dann irgendwann
ankommen bei
ja, wie wäre es denn bei Beleidigungen
gegen Politiker? Oder wie wäre es
denn generell bei Beleidigungen?
Könnte man das ja auch einsetzen. Oder generellen
Zugriff von der Polizei drauf?
Oder wie wäre das denn überhaupt, wie wäre es denn
wenn man das auch gleich bei Hassrede
einsetzen. Hassrede kannst du ja auch
alles irgendwie drunter packen. Ist alles irgendwie dann gleich
Hassrede. Ja, dann müssen wir das
natürlich auch mal kurz, müssen wir mal kurz mal das Handy
anzapfen von dem Typ, ob da nicht Hassrede drauf
ist. Sobald das da ist,
das kann ich euch sagen, das ist so sicher wie das Arme in der Kirche,
wird das versucht werden auszuweiten.
Und dann ist es halt problematisch.
Weil dann, wenn du wirklich
Angst haben musst,
dass schon nach falschen Worten
in Zukunft dein Handy durchsucht wird,
dann ist halt mit freier Meinungsäußerung vorbei.
Generell, spätestens mit Klarnamenpflicht ist das vorbei.
Du musst anonym dich äußern können,
weil es ja durchaus auch kritische Meinungen gibt,
die nicht gerne gesehen sind.
Und das musst du anonym machen können,
ohne dass du Angst haben musst, deinen Job zu verlieren.
Oder andere Probleme zu bekommen.
Dann ist eh vorbei.
Und was ich auch ein bisschen fragwürdig finde ist, dass ich tatsächlich auf Twitter Leute gesehen habe, die das gut finden.
Und ich glaube, das liegt daran, weil es zur Zeit...
Ich glaube, das liegt daran...
Weil diese Leute sich für moralisch quasi überlegen dadurch halten können.
Ihr kennt ja sicherlich dieses Phänomen auf Twitter.
Da wird quasi den ganzen, also gibt es einige Accounts, ja.
Die posten den ganzen Tag, wie moralisch verwerflich das ist, was andere Leute machen.
Und sie würden das ja nie machen.
So sinngemäß.
Und das sind Leute, die quasi sich den ganzen Tag so aufspielen wollen, als haben sie den moralischen Highground.
So könnten wir das Ganze ja mal nennen.
Und das sind dann auch genauso Leute, die das auf Twitter irgendwie gut finden.
Weil sie haben ja den moralischen Highground, so nach dem Motto.
Wer dagegen ist, der hat natürlich auch was dagegen, dass man Kinder schützt und solche Geschichten.
Also da gibt es jede Menge Leute in dieser Richtung.
Das finde ich immer ganz weird, Champ.
Weil, was diese Leute nicht bedenken ist, der Wind kann sich auch ganz schnell mal drehen.
Wer glaubst du, denkt nicht so von sich.
Ich bin mir bei vielen Sachen sicher, dass ich definitiv nicht den moralischen Highground habe.
Ich habe euch in letzter Zeit schon öfters mal gesagt, ich ernähre mich jetzt teilweise vegan.
Was aber, nehme ich jetzt einfach mal als Beispiel.
Was allerdings nicht daran liegt, oder zum größten Teil nicht daran liegt, dass mir das Tierwohl auf einmal so wichtig ist, sondern für meine eigene Gesundheit.
Weil ich nicht mehr so viel Fleisch essen will.
Um nicht zu sagen, das Tierwohl ist mir eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Das ist vielleicht ein nettes Beiwerk.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich bei vielen sage, ich glaube auch nicht, dass ich den moralischen Highcrown habe, weil ich öfters sage, dass ich Menschen generell nicht mag und sowas.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass ich so bin.
Natürlich habe ich manche Sachen, von denen ich echt überzeugt bin und sage, so ist es und so muss es eigentlich sein.
Aber ich gehe nicht auf Twitter hin und poste den ganzen Tag, oh guckt mal da, der XY hat das und das gemacht.
Ja sowas würde ich ja auf gar keinen Fall machen, das ist ja total verwerflich und sowas.
oder ich poste auch nicht auf irgendwelche Tweets von anderen Leuten so nach dem Motto,
oh ja, volle Zustimmung, sehr gut, weiter so, sehr wichtig, dass das mal gesagt wird und solche Geschichten.
Das geht mir auf Twitter immer übelst auf den Sack.
Also ich würde sagen, ich denke nicht von mir so.
Oder ich habe da eine halbwegs realistische Einschätzung noch, dass ich auch meine Fehler habe, ja.
Das Letzte, was ich jetzt dazu noch sagen wollte,
was den Leuten nicht ganz klar ist,
die das quasi feiern,
oder ich muss das anders sagen,
ich habe den Eindruck, es gibt viele Leute,
die feiern Entscheidungen,
nicht weil sie die Entscheidung an sich gut finden,
sondern weil die Auswirkung
einer Entscheidung
gegen Leute geht,
die sie nicht mögen.
Versteht ihr, was ich meine?
Also es wird irgendwas entschieden. Diese Entscheidung an sich ist gar nicht so das, was die Leute interessiert, sondern die Auswirkung dieser Entscheidung richtet sich gegen Leute, die sie nicht mögen.
und dann findet man das ganz geil, aber
aber
ich sag mal sowas wie zum Beispiel Trusted Flagger und sowas, ja
also es gibt, es soll Stellen geben, beziehungsweise gibt es Stellen
die auf Social Media quasi Posts mit höherer Priorität
melden können, wo man dann auch, wo dann die Anbieter halt auch quasi verpflichtet
sein sollen, sich das anzugucken und sowas, so. Jetzt überlegt euch mal, wenn diese
Trusted Flagger quasi
besetzt sind mit
einem
mit dem Großteil der Leute aus einem
bestimmten Spektrum.
Ja, oder aus einem bestimmten Lager.
Das heißt, das werden natürlich viel mehr
und viel energischer
Sachen gemeldet, die quasi
nicht dieser Weltanschauung entsprechen.
Die Einführung
dieser Trusted Flagger wurde von
vielen gefeiert,
weil man gesagt hat, okay,
das richtet sich ja zum größten Teil gegen
keine Ahnung, rechte Hetze und sowas, richtet sich das.
Und dann haben die Leute gesagt, oh ja, das ist gut, das ist gut.
Weil die haben nicht gesagt, es ist gut, dass es Trusted Flagger gibt.
Die haben gesagt, es ist gut, dass es sich gegen rechte Hetze richtet und die mögen wir nicht.
Die haben nicht darüber nachgedacht, dass sich das ganz schnell drehen kann.
Wenn man sich das jetzt anguckt, dass in einigen Bundesländern die AfD beispielsweise bald die absolute Mehrheit hat,
Was meint ihr dann, wie solche Sachen, wenn man sowas hat wie Trusted Flagger, wie sich da der Wind relativ schnell drehen kann?
Also man muss sich mal überlegen, eine Entscheidung ist nicht automatisch gut, nur weil sich aktuell die Auswirkungen dieser Entscheidung gegen Leute richten, die man nicht mag.
Das kann sich ganz schnell um 180 Grad drehen und dann richtet es sich gegen einen selbst.
Deswegen sollte man sich immer mal überlegen, ist es das wert, nur weil man glaubt, man hat gerade den krassen moralischen Highground und kann da auf Twitter drüber rumposaunen.
Ist es das wirklich wert?
Oder sollte man sich darüber Gedanken machen, ob die Entscheidung an sich vielleicht nicht so clever ist?
Das siehst du halt auch total oft, dass die Leute sich keine Gedanken drüber machen, sondern nur, jawoll, das richtet sich ja gegen Leute, die ich aktuell nicht mag, die eine andere Weltanschauung haben wie ich.
Und deswegen finde ich das jetzt gut.
Ja, wart mal ab. Wart mal ab in 4, 5, 6, 7, 10 Jahren.
Ob das dann immer noch so gut ist, wenn sich der Wind vielleicht gedreht hat und sich das gegen einen selbst richtet.
Da denkt aber kaum einer dran.
So.
Fertig.
Falls jemand mich fragt, was ich zum Thema Chatkontrolle und solchen Überwachungsdingern denke,
ich schreibe mir das auf da muss ich das nicht nämlich da muss ich das nicht
nehme ich neue erzählen hier das habe ich am 12 7 am 12 7 zu 23 minuten erzählt
So.
Kann ich das nämlich einfach verlinken und gut ist.
Weil ich reg mich da immer auf bei.
Oh, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ups, was ist das?
Ja, das...
Das war es noch nie.
Ich finde, das ist auch ein Spruch, der
triggert mich immer. Das Internet darf kein
rechtsfreier Raum und sowas sein. Das ist es nicht.
War es auch noch nie. Das wird immer
so getan, als ob. Das war es
noch nie. Das wird immer,
das ist auch so eine Standardbegründung,
so nach dem Motto, oh, wir müssen da was verschärfen
und hier und da und mehr überwachen, weil das Internet
ist ja kein rechtsfreier Raum. Das war noch nie,
noch nie zu keiner Zeit war das Internet
rechtsfreier Raum.
Ich weiß, dass du das jetzt so
nicht gemeint hast, wie ich es jetzt, aber es gibt
Leute, die schreiben das ja so, weil sie es wirklich denken.
So.
Exzellent oder auch nicht.
Traue ich mich, Leute?
Traue ich mich, das zu updaten?
Traue ich mich nicht mal, Art User Repos zu updaten?
Hast du das mit dem Lego YouTube?
Ne, hab ich nicht mitbekommen.
Was? Der hat
für dich immer über
C++ gepostet.
Wie jemand postet,
das C++ sagt.
Aber was hat das mit C++ zu tun?
Ich sehe hier
nichts C++ mäßiges.
Ich wurde schon genug ragebaited gerade.
So, was? Welche Post sollte ich mir noch angucken?
Hier vom ZDF irgendwas, oder?
Da hatten wir doch gerade noch...
Ja.
Kamerapflicht. Überwacht die EU jetzt alle Autofahrer.
Neuwagen in der EU müssen nun eine Kamera an Bord haben,
die prüft, ob der Fahrer am Steuer abgelenkt ist.
Manche wittern den Überwachung...
Jetzt, ahnen wir schon.
Was steckt hinter der Aufregung?
Na, mal gucken.
Da bin ich ja froh, dass das ZDF das für uns jetzt wieder einordnet.
Einordnet ist für mich ja auch schon das Unwort des Jahres 2026, Alter.
Mehr als 9500... Ja, blablabla.
Eine Maßnahme, mit der die...
Alle Neufahrzeuge müssen in der EU nur mit einer Kamera ausgestattet sein,
Die erkennt, ob mein Fahrer abgelenkt ist, um ihn das zu halten.
Ja, und was ist mit Autos, die verkauft werden, aber halt, also die ich neu kaufe, aber die noch nicht neu hergestellt wurden?
Internetnutzer besorgt wegen Überwachung.
Alter, es sollte jeder besorgt sein, nicht nur Internetnutzer.
Ich hoffe ja mal, dass die meisten auch Internetbenutzer sind.
Moment.
Was? Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt habe ich eine blöde Frage.
Was hat ein Portal, also eine Seite, die sich mit Edelmetalle beschäftigt,
mit einem Artikel über Kameras im Auto zu tun?
Hey
Muss man nicht verstehen
Aha
Okay, der Chat kennt den anscheinend
Ich hab noch nie gehört
Oh, ich muss die Klimalage ausmachen
Wird's zu kalt an den Füßen
Was ist das?
Totale Überwachung im Auto, bla bla bla.
Wie funktioniert die Kameratechnik?
Die zum Erkennen des Fahrbewegungs benutzt Kameras, die überall fest und abdecken.
Ja.
Meint ihr, mein Auto hat auch sowas?
Chat.
Meint ihr, ich hab, der ist ja auch relativ neu.
Mein Fiat hat sowas bestimmt nicht.
der ist da zu low IQ für.
Ich hab einen Fiat 500E. Hat der auch sowas?
Der hat sowas?
Also, also, werde ich quasi
schon komplett überwacht, oder wie?
Ne, ich will das
gar nicht wissen.
Okay.
Es erstellt kein stundenlanges Videoarchiv.
Ja, das glaube ich auch nicht, dass es das macht.
Allein schon der Speicher und alles drum, das glaube ich nicht.
Es ist den Herstellern untersagt.
Ja gut, wir warten.
Mal warten, bis Kontrolle 2.0 kommt.
Hast du Funktion zur Müdigkeiterkennung? Keine Ahnung.
Naja.
Wer hat Zugriff auf die Daten?
Sie sollen nur lokal auf dem jeweiligen Fahrzeug verarbeiten und nicht ins Netz über.
Also weder zum Hersteller noch zur Behörde.
Ja gut, wie gesagt, bis zu Kontrolle 2.0.
Das, also, das Ding ist halt
Ich glaube, ich glaube auch nicht
Dass das jetzt
Zur unmittelbaren
Massenüberwachung aller Autofahrer führen wird
Dafür, glaube ich, eignet sich die Technik
So wie sie jetzt ist nicht
Aber, wir dürfen nicht vergessen
Das ist
Also quasi Überwachung einzuführen ist ein schrittweiser Prozess.
Mit dieser Autogeneration kommt die Kamera, mit der nächsten Autogeneration kommt KI-gestützte Auswertung,
mit der nächsten Generation kommt Snapshots zum Server schicken,
mit der nächsten Generation kommt die letzten 15 Sekunden an die EU schicken und solche Geschichten.
Das sind immer Scheibchen, wie das passiert.
Dann kommen Mikrofone.
Also ja, das ist jetzt alles Verschwörungstheorie, könnte sein.
Aber wir haben das mit Chatkontrolle gesehen und mit geplanter Chatkontrolle 2.0,
dass die ganz klar Ambitionen zur Überwachung haben.
Ich glaube, das kann ja wirklich keiner mehr leugnen mittlerweile.
Und dass das ein Einstieg in die Richtung der Überwachung von Autofahrern sein soll,
so als aller kleiner erster Schritt
kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen in Zukunft.
Ja, klar.
Haben wir den Vortrag schon mal geschaut?
Ich schaue meistens
keine Kongress-Talks,
weil die so lang sind.
Welchen Talk meinst du denn?
...
VW Datenskandal?
Ne.
Was ist da?
Was gab es da beim TCC?
Was oder wie?
Livestream?
Das da?
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Aber da gibt es leider den...
Okay, suchen wir mal danach.
Auto.
Wir wissen, wo da ein Auto steht.
Hier.
Also das ist mir jetzt ein bisschen lang.
War das gerade der Anzeigenhauptmeister?
Habe ich das richtig erkannt?
Ja.
Was ist aus dem eigentlich geworden?
Lange nichts mehr gehört.
Erste Hälfte ist Erklärung, zweite Hälfte
Laden. Okay.
Das können wir uns tatsächlich dann mal
angucken.
Der ist komplett abgedreht. Aha.
Habe ich nicht irgendwo gelesen, der wollte sich angeblich das alte Haus vom Drachenlord kaufen?
Der Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Da gab es doch mal irgendwie so ein Gerücht, dass das so ist. Oder hat er das gemacht?
Keiner. Ich verfolge das nicht. Es interessiert mich auch nicht.
Das Haus ist abgerissen, okay.
Alles klar.
So, what's new in .NET 11?
Das können wir uns tatsächlich mal kurz angucken, weil das interessiert mich.
Und dann gucken wir uns GitHub-Trends an.
Ah gut, CD-Trennung.
Moment, das ist doch falsch hier.
Falsch.
Clear Language.
Ey, das habe ich auch nicht verfolgt.
Ganz ehrlich, es gibt kaum was, wirklich kaum was, was mich weniger interessiert als deutsches Streamer-Drama.
Das geht mir so extrem ab.
Also das geht mir hardcore am Arsch vorbei, deutsches Streamer-Drama.
Ich habe früher ab und zu bei Kaiser die Videos geguckt.
Aber ich kann mir dieses, ich kann mir deutsches YouTube- und Twitch-Drama, das kann ich mir nicht geben.
Das ist so unglaublich dumm.
Also ich gebe mir auch kein internationales YouTube- und Twitch-Drama.
Aber das ist, das ist so dumm, Alter.
Außerdem interessiert mich das nicht.
Die Leute haben alle einen Dachschaden.
Ich darf das sagen, ich habe zertifizierten Dachschaden.
Ja, mittlerweile.
Aber die haben auch alle übelsten Dachschaden.
So, schauen wir mal.
Ja.
Mein Chat ist sehr angenehm, was das angeht.
Wir haben halt nur High-IQ-Leute da.
Was natürlich auch die ganzen Prime-Subs belegen.
Nur High-IQ-Leute da.
Da ist es kein Wunder, dass der Chat auch High-IQ ist.
So, wir gucken mal ganz kurz drüber, was es Neues in .NET 11 gibt, weil es ist ja bald soweit.
.NET 11 kommt, glaube ich, in drei Monaten oder so raus.
Okay, in vier Monaten.
Es dauert gar nicht mehr so lang.
Ich will nur mal kurz drüber gucken.
Minimum Hardware Requirements juckt mich nicht.
Runtime Native Async.
Ja, das ist ganz nice, aber das ist mir jetzt auch nicht so wichtig.
JIT-Improving juckt mich auch nicht.
ProSex Expansion with Run-and-Capture-Helpers.
Fire-and-Forget-Launchers.
Okay, man kann einfache Prozesse.
Compression.
Bessere Base 64-APs.
Okay, nice.
System Text JSON-Improvements.
Auch gut.
Open Telemetry-Metrics.
Aha, auch nicht verkehrt.
Discriminate Unions Gap Holding.
Whatever.
Also ich weiß, dass es in C Sharp jetzt Union Types gibt.
TAR Archiv Format.
Okay, Console.
PLS Handshakes.
Link Improvements.
Okay, das hält jetzt alles in Grenzen.
Oh, okay.
Das hier.
Das hier ist eigentlich das wirklich Interessante.
Was ist denn?
was ist denn Collection Expression
Argument?
Was ist denn das?
Wie sieht denn das aus?
Wollen die, dass das langsam nach C++ aussieht,
oder was?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was zum...
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Values, 1, 2, 3.
Okay, with
Capacity
Hä?
Man kann da
ein Capacity
Argument
Aber
Jetzt mal eine ganz doofe Frage
Kann ich das nicht jetzt schon machen?
Kann ich nicht jetzt schon sagen
New List of Strings und da eine Capacity
im Konstruktor übergeben?
Kann ich doch
dann verstehe ich den Sinn davon, ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Nur mal so.
Also.
Also ich kann
ich kann jetzt so machen.
Ich kann jetzt so machen.
So.
Alternativ
Alternativ könnte ich auch
war, Names gleich
New List
String
String, keine Ahnung
Capacity, was weiß ich
10 machen
und dann einfach sagen, gut da war ich
jetzt, Names add
äh ja, äh Values
so, ich glaube es ist nicht add, es ist add range oder
sowas, ne
das könnte ich auch machen, ups, no, no, no
so
jetzt ist halt die Frage
ist das da oben, also das ist doch
das gleiche im Endeffekt, oder?
Ich weiß ja nicht,
ob es direkt an die Stelle im Konstruktor kommt
und so, aber im Prinzip kommt ja da
unterm Strich das gleiche raus, oder beziehungsweise
im Prinzip so, ja, okay.
So, also im Prinzip kommt ja
kommt da alles das gleiche raus.
So.
Warum brauche ich denn das? Das hier ist doch
super lesbar, überhaupt kein Problem.
Das ist doch super lesbar.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Den Sinn verstehe ich nicht.
Okay, das ist,
wenn man die Collection Expression
sonntags verwenden will.
Das ist sonst die Sharp Feature, wo ich mir halt echt denke,
brauchst das wirklich?
Lohnt es sich für so
ein Feature die Sprache unnötig
kompliziert zu machen? Oder was heißt unnötig?
Lohnt es sich dafür die Sprache
komplizierter zu machen?
Also bei Go bin ich ja immer am meckern,
dass Go teilweise zu minimalistisch ist.
Bei C Sharp muss ich mittlerweile sagen,
ich fände es eigentlich ganz gut,
wenn sie mal 1, 2 Releases machen würden,
um alte Features fertig zu bauen
und ein bisschen aufzuräumen,
anstatt neue Sachen einzuführen.
Das sind so Dinger,
keine Ahnung, ob es das wirklich gebraucht hat.
Ja, wenn es so weitergeht,
sieht es wirklich wie ein C++ aus in 10 Jahren.
Gut, das stimmt nicht,
weil in 10 Jahren sieht C++ noch viel
beschissener aus als C++ jetzt.
In 10 Jahren sind wir bei
bei, wo sind wir da?
Bei C++32 oder so, gell?
Ne.
Bei C++35
sind wir in 10 Jahren.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen? In C++35?
Ha! Monkeis!
Ich will gar nicht wissen, was da drin ist.
In C, ohne Scheiß, Leute.
In C++35
Ist das hier gültige Syntax?
Wobei, wenn ich es mir recht überlege...
Vielleicht ist das jetzt sogar schon gültige Syntax.
Man weiß es nicht.
Wobei, da waren zu viele normale Zeichen drin.
Da waren zu viele normale Zeichen drin.
Ich glaube eher...
Das ist gültige C++-Syntax dann.
Und ohne Mistchat, haltet ihr es für ausgeschlossen, dass das mal gültige C++-Syntax wird?
Ganz ehrlich, ganz ehrlich
Glaubt ihr, dass das bei C++35
Vielleicht
Seid ihr euch sicher, dass das bei C++35
Nicht
Gültige Syntax sein könnte
Ey, ey
Tommy, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie du das meinst
Aber das ist jetzt gültige Syntax
In C++26, ne
hier mit diesen Hütchen davor.
Das ist ja gerade der Gag dabei.
Das ist...
Die 300 Dinger.
Okay.
Also, jetzt kommt das eigentlich
spannende Feature von C Sharp 15, glaube ich.
Union Types.
Das gucken wir uns aber auch mal in einem Stream
an.
Man kann jetzt Union Types basteln.
Also sprich, man braucht dann keinen gemeinsamen Basetype mit abstrakter Base Class und sowas.
Man kann jetzt einfach sagen, beziehungsweise man kann dann auch einen Unit-Type machen von Types, die einem nicht gehören im Endeffekt, ja.
Also ich kann jetzt einfach sagen, Union Pet und das kann dann nur Cat, Dog oder Bird sein.
Und stellt euch mal vor, also das sind keine Klassen von euch.
Ja, man könnte das sicherlich mit abstrakter Base Class oder so ein bisschen rumtricksen.
tricksen ja wofür das und für das halt richtig geil ist dass du dann zum beispiel auch result
types und sowas machen kannst dass du dann dass du dann ja genau du kannst sagen number float
double int und sowas in der richtung und ja das kann sein dass mir odin gefallen würde als language
aber da ist solche nicht language haben kein ökosystem das halt das problem und dass dieses
feature das bearbeiten die irgendwie schon seit acht jahren oder so dran das ist richtig heißt
dass das kommt. Das ist zum Beispiel auch richtig cool.
Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr habt
ihr habt eine HTTP
API, okay?
Und diese API kann drei
verschiedene Responses haben.
Wie kann eine Response haben?
Sagen wir hier, was weiß ich.
Ja, ihr habt irgendwie eine API.
Hier HTTP
Doppelpunkt, Doppelslash
Omega keck w.lul
Slash API
slash, ups, was muss ich jetzt sagen,
slash api, slash
was ist hier, v2
slash
joke, so.
So, und
wenn ihr das Ding aufruft,
so, sagen wir hier 2, so, der zweite Witz.
Wenn ihr das aufruft, kriegt ihr den JSON zurück
mit, ja, whatever,
keine Ahnung, id2
text 0w.
So, das ist
die gültige Response.
Wenn ihr die api
aufruft mit, äh, was weiß ich,
150, dann gibt es
eine Response mit
keine Ahnung, hier
Error, äh,
ID not found oder sowas.
So, und wenn ihr
das aufruft mit X,
dann kriegt ihr ein, äh,
keine Ahnung, 404.
Irgendwas habt ihr zurecht gemacht,
ja, im Kopf.
Und das könntet ihr jetzt mit Union Types
tatsächlich
repräsentieren.
da könntet ihr sagen, wir machen einen Union-Type.
Und zwar ein Union-Type.
So, keine Ahnung.
Äh, hier.
Joke-Response oder sowas.
Und dann könnte man sowas sagen wie, ähm,
ja, irgendwie weiß ich nicht.
Joke.
Äh, Error.
Oder, oder
HTTP-Error.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ich gebe zu, das ist tatsächlich das allerschönste Beispiel,
weil man versteht, was gemeint ist.
und und das kann ich dann einfach return und ist dann eins davon das ist eigentlich richtig
nice also das ist das ist richtig das ist ein richtig richtig nice feature und und angeblich
kommt ja damit dann auch eingebaute result types und sowas im im dotnet framework c sharp 15 result
types habe ich mir sagen lassen irgendwo
ich will mir eine sollte auch result types geben schon vordefinierte
Das ist halt echt cool.
Also finde ich nice.
Was? Typed Results?
Heißt das so?
Das kann sein, dass ich das meine.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber gibt's das nicht schon?
Ist das nicht...
Ist das nicht schon das Neueste?
Ey, dann gibt's...
Keine Ahnung, irgendwas...
Wir gucken uns das an, wenn's released ist.
Aber das ist ein richtig geiles Feature.
Das ist eines der wenigen Features,
die die letzten 5-6 Jahre in C Sharp eingeführt wurden...
werden, wo ich sagen würde,
ja, die will ich unbedingt haben.
Es gab viele aus meiner Sicht überflüssige Features die letzten zehn Jahre.
Also Record Types würde ich zum Beispiel auch behalten wollen.
Pattern Matching finde ich nice.
Ich müsste mir mal die Version angucken und dann sagen, was ich behalten will und was nicht.
Wollen wir das mal kurz machen?
Ähm.
Ja, oh mein Gott.
Wie kompliziert.
Public Record Class Closed.
Was?
Closed Modifier.
Wo ist denn der Closed Modifier?
Ach hier.
Public Closed Record Class.
Ja, übertreibt halt mal mit Schlüsselwörtern wieder.
So, also das Feature, Union Types,
das will ich auf jeden Fall haben.
Beste. So, ein 14, was gab's denn?
14 Neues.
Also, Extension Members, das finde ich auch sehr nice.
Finde ich mega nice.
Das würde ich auch unbedingt behalten wollen.
Du kannst jetzt Static Classes und Interfaces
und alles extenden.
Das ist richtig cool.
Die Syntax finde ich nicht schön, aber das würde ich auch
auf jeden Fall behalten wollen.
Ja, das ist nice to have.
Das kann man schon lassen.
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Okay, hätte es auch nicht unbedingt gebraucht.
Macht es ein bisschen einfacher.
Feedback Properties.
Ja, auch nice.
Würde ich auch behalten wollen.
Brauche ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, müsste nicht unbedingt sein.
Das hätte ich auch nicht gebraucht.
Egal, das dauert jetzt zu lange,
bis wir das alles durchgucken.
Aber ich sag mal so, 50% der Features
finde ich sehr nice.
Die anderen 50%, wo ich mich frage,
Okay, das hat vielleicht Microsoft nur eingeführt, weil sie es selbst brauchen.
Oder weil ihnen nichts anderes mehr eingefallen ist.
Also, schauen wir mal, was auf GitHub diese Woche so trendet.
Oh, Chat, ich muss ja nachher noch eine Runde rennen gehen.
Ich muss mal kurz auf meine Uhr gucken, was ich heute machen muss.
Wartet mal.
Garmin stellt's.
Run.
Workout.
46 Minuten Base-Ausdauertraining.
Also 46 Minuten locker Jogsorn.
Es wird heute warm, oder?
Oh ja.
Ich bin es ja mittlerweile gewöhnt.
Das ist warm.
Ach doch, das geht schon.
Oder ich fahre in den Wald und renne da eine Runde.
46 Minuten werde ich schon aushalten.
Gestern war ich eine Stunde, Stunde 10 unterwegs.
Habe über 11 Kilometer gerannt.
2,29 Radeln.
Mein Fahrrad ist kaputt.
Ich habe es immer noch nicht repariert.
Ich habe nur noch meinen Indoor-Trainer hier.
Der noch funktioniert.
Wie gesagt, mein Fahrrad ist kaputt.
Ich müsste wahrscheinlich das Schaltauge tauschen.
Dann geht es wieder.
Ich bin gegen irgendeinen Baumstamm oder so gefahren.
Und dann...
Seitdem bleibt die Kette nicht mehr hinten drauf.
Weil es irgendwas verbogen ist.
Da musste ich einige Kilometer durch den Wald laufen mit den Schuhen vom Fahrrad.
Das war richtig nervig und da musste ich mich von einem Uber abholen lassen.
Das konnte man nicht mehr fixen unterwegs.
Das klingt knackig, ja.
Ich fahre fast jeden Tag eine Viertelstunde Indoor, fahre ich mich warm und dann gehe ich meine Laufeinheit machen.
setze mich auf den indoor trainer war locker eine viertelstunde dann habe ich so ein puls
von 120 irgendwie 120 125 130 und dann ich ziehe mich vorher komplett an mit allem auch
mit laufschuhen und so das ist keine geile kraft übertragen aus fahrrad weil die halt
gedämpft sind aber scheiße dafür fahr ich das ja nicht und dann gehe ich direkt raus und rennen
meine, zwischen,
tja, es ist immer so zwischen 40 Minuten
und 56 Minuten,
weil es ist einfach viel
angenehmer, wenn man ein bisschen aufgewärmt
ist. Den Fehler habe ich früher gemacht.
Ich bin früher immer rausgegangen,
ich habe meine Uhr angezogen, bin rausgegangen, bin
losgelaufen und die ersten
1,5 Kilometer und so, die waren immer so übelst
anstrengend. Ich habe mir gedacht, boah, Alter, hoffentlich
ist bald vorbei. Aber seitdem
ich mich jetzt eine Viertelstunde
auf dem Fahrrad einfach mal
warm fahre, kann ich direkt
locker, flockig, easy loslaufen und es schockt
mich nicht mehr. Also
aufwärmen ist gar nicht verkehrt. Machst du auch
Krafttraining? Nö.
Ich hab jetzt aber Zugang
zum Fitness, zu zwei
oder drei, glaub ich sogar,
Fitnessstudios bei uns,
weil ich habe
einen,
ich habe hier
was abgeschlossen und zwar
nennt sich das Ganze
Wellpass
Das da
Das bezahlt nämlich
Mein Arbeitgeber
Hier
Das bezahlt mein Arbeitgeber
Und damit kann ich in drei Fitnessstudios
Hier gehen
Oder in zwei verschiedene Schwimmbäder
Weil ich wollte auch mal wieder anfangen
zu schwimmen. Ey, und wenn ich dann
angefangen hab zu schwimmen,
dann mach ich beim Gelnhausen Triathlon
mit nächstes Jahr. Das ist nur ganz
kurz. Das ist
kein Ironman oder so. Das ist wirklich kurz.
Das sind nur ein paar Kilometer.
Aber dafür muss ich erstmal
dafür bezahlte Arbeitgeber das zu
100%.
Das ist eine gute
Frage.
Ich musste da keine
Kontodaten und sowas angeben. Also
wahrscheinlich schon, ja.
Ich guck mal, my membership.
Unlimited.
Also ich hab da keine
keine
Bezahlinformationen hinterlegt.
Also das muss der Arbeitgeber komplett bezahlen.
Ach, der Rest geht vom Lohn ab.
Okay, ja egal.
Es subventioniert ein bisschen.
Das reicht mir.
Deswegen.
Ja, vor allem, weil die Schwimmbäder hier drin sind, ist nice.
Und was auch geil ist bei uns hier,
ich brauche ungefähr...
Ah, so 4 Kilometer, 4, 5 Kilometer.
Sag mal, 5 Kilometer.
Brauche ich...
zum Schwimmbad hier in
Arnau.
Und
da habe ich mir überlegt, ich könnte das so machen.
Ich habe so eine...
Ich habe so eine Weste hier.
Sowas hier in der Richtung.
Sowas ähnliches wie das hier.
Man muss das mal von hinten sehen.
Ich habe so eine Running
Weste.
Und da habe ich mir überlegt,
Hanau Schwimmbad aber auch schlimm
Keine Ahnung, ich war da schon eine Weile nicht mehr
Dann habe ich mir überlegt, ich könnte das so machen
Ich könnte mir da einfach hinten rein in die Weste
Eine Badehose
Und
Ein Handtuch oder so reinstecken
Vielleicht noch was kleines zu trinken vorne rein
Dann renne ich 5 Kilometer
Zum Schwimmbad
dann schwimme ich eine Runde
und dann renne ich wieder heim.
Das wäre eine richtig
nice
Übung eigentlich.
Fünf Kilometer rennen,
bisschen, bisschen,
warum brauche ich Badelatschen?
Ich kann auch barfuß laufen.
Im Freibad renne ich alle barfuß rum.
Oder meinst du,
weil ich sonst Fußpilz kriege.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch ein Fahrrad für den Triathlon.
Na, ich hab ja ein Fahrrad.
Aber ich hab kein Triathlon-Fahrrad.
Aber wenn ich, wie gesagt,
wenn ich bei dem Gelnhausen-Triathlon mitmache,
das sind, glaube ich, nur,
ich weiß es gar nicht,
30 Kilometer Fahrrad fahren oder sowas.
Oder, nee, ich glaube sogar noch weniger.
Ich glaube sogar noch weniger.
Das packe ich mit meinem Rad auch.
Warte mal hier.
Ausrufezeichen Fahrrad.
Aktuell habe ich das hier.
Auch wenn es gerade ein bisschen verbogen ist,
wenn ich es reparieren muss.
Aber das geht schon klar, finde ich.
Das Bike.
für was weiß ich, 30 Kilometer
oder weniger ist es.
Ja, mit kaputtem Schaltauge nicht.
Ja, 30 Kilometer
kann ich damit auch Triathlon fahren.
Da brauche ich nicht so ein geiles Triathlon-Aero-Fahrrad
mit
Armauflage.
Ja, dann ist es das.
Genau. 500 Meter schwimmen,
20 Kilometer Radfahren, 5 Kilometer
laufen. Das ist easy. Das packe ich
easy.
Das park ich easy
Das ist keine Strecke
Also 20 Kilometer kann ich da mit jedem
Mit jedem Fahrrad fahren
Und
Soll ich euch
Übrigens der Preis ist totaler Blödsinn
Das habe ich nicht dafür bezahlt
Soll ich euch mal sagen
Was ich im Nachhinein
Wirklich extrem nice
An dem Fahrrad finde
Was ich mir ursprünglich eigentlich nur just for fun
Gekauft habe, weil es mich technisch interessiert hat
Wo ich mir jetzt aber kein Fahrrad mehr kaufen würde, wo ich mir aber gar kein Fahrrad mehr ohne kaufen würde, elektronische Schaltung, genau.
Ja, elektronische Schaltung ist so geil.
Das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Keine Züge, schaltet so schnell und direkt und genau und alles.
Elektronische Schaltung ist einfach geil.
Und was mir eigentlich am meisten Spaß macht an der elektronischen Schaltung, wie lange hält der Akku?
Also ich habe das jetzt letztens geladen, nachdem es den Winter über in der Garage stand.
Oh boah, keine Ahnung. Der hält lange. Der hält lange. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie lange der hält.
Also der Akku ist hier im Rohr drin.
So, was ich halt mega nice finde bei dieser elektronischen Schaltung ist, ich weiß nicht, ob man es erkennt.
Erkennt man es hier?
Hier oben drauf, hier,
sind...
Kennt man nicht.
Sind Knöpfe.
Man sieht das nicht innen.
Hier oben drauf.
Hier oben drauf sind Knöpfe.
Und die kann man, also links und rechts jeweils ein Knopf,
und die kann man mit seinem Fahrradcomputer pären.
und dann kann man seinen Fahrradcomputer quasi steuern,
ohne dass man die Hände vom Lenker
nehmen muss. Das ist richtig geil.
Man kann es ja da noch umschalten
zwischen Karte
und Steigungsansicht
und genaue Daten
und alles.
Das ist mega pock.
Also wie gesagt, elektronische
Schaltung könnte ich
jedem empfehlen. Das ist richtig geil.
Das einzige, was ich an dem Fahrrad modifiziert habe, ist die Kassette.
Standardmäßig ist da eine 11-34 drauf und ich habe eine 11-40 oder 11-42 drauf gemacht.
Offiziell wird das Ganze nicht unterstützt.
Wenn man keinen Akku hat, kann man nicht mehr schalten.
Richtig.
Das schaltet dann ein letztes Mal, glaube ich noch,
in einen halbwegs angenehmen Gang
und dann kannst du nicht mehr schalten.
Aber der Akku geht ja nicht einfach von jetzt auf gleich leer.
Ich meine, du kriegst eine Warnung.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Du kriegst eine Warnung und kannst dann irgendwie,
was weiß ich noch, 200 Kilometer fahren oder so.
So.
Und.
dass halt ein bisschen bessere Übersetzung
habe. Also offiziell ist das nicht supported.
Hier 11 bis 42.
Macht die Schaltung aber trotzdem mit.
Ja.
Also das ist wirklich
ein nices Rad.
Würde ich mir wieder kaufen.
Ich will gerade mal kurz gucken
bei Rose. Was haben die denn?
Was gibt es denn aktuell so an Bikes mit elektronischer Schaltung?
Also ich kaufe mir jetzt garantiert kein neues Fahrrad, nur weil mein Schaltauge wahrscheinlich kaputt ist.
Every Day.
Every Day ist das mit...
Race E-Cravel.
Okay, was gibt es hier bei Adventure?
Adventure.
zum Backroad.
Gibt's das? Das gibt's
bestimmt mit elektronischer Schaltung mittlerweile.
Gescheit.
Ah ja.
Meine Güte, ey.
Ja, wo gibt's denn die
unterschiedlichen Modelle?
Ja, zum Kauf, genau.
Ey.
Leute.
Der wichtigste Knopf geht nicht.
WTF?
Was ist mit euch los?
Hä?
Der wichtigste Knopf ist broken.
Oben rechts.
Ja, ich weiß, aber warum ist da ein Knopf und da geht nicht?
Das ist Webdesign-Fail, Alter.
DI2. Haben die eine DI2?
Wie, es gibt keine
DI2 mehr? Es gibt nur die...
Ach doch, da hier. Ich wollte gerade sagen,
es gibt nur die SRAM.
Ja,
GRX
825 DI2.
Also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
da gefällt mir meine blaue
Lackierung besser.
Oder, Chad, was meint ihr?
Hier.
Klassisch.
Klassisch blau.
Versus bunt mit Konfetti.
Ich weiß nicht.
Mir gefällt mein Blau aus besser.
Was mich jetzt natürlich interessiert, was ist denn da?
Und ist nicht so hübsch, finde ich auch.
Oh, guck mal.
10 bis 51 hat er sogar.
Was haben die vorne für ein Kettenblatt drauf?
Steht das irgendwo technische Daten?
Ausstattung.
40.
40 durch 51.
Da kommst du gut den Berg hoch.
Ich habe 31 zu 42.
Okay, guck mal.
Oder habe ich nur 40?
Ungefähr.
Also ungefähr die gleiche Übersetzung.
Untersetzung ist es in dem Fall ja schon.
Na gut.
Genug Fahrradstelz.
Du fährst das hier.
Cube ist der größte deutsche Hersteller.
Wusste dir das?
Was Fahrräder angeht.
Cube hat auch bei vielen Sachen immer mit Abstand
das beste Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis.
Reaction Hybrid.
Ist das ein E-Bike?
Weil das so stabil hier in der Mitte aussieht.
Ist ein E-Bike, ja.
Sieht so...
Das sieht irgendwie so kurz vorne aus,
weil das hier hinten so
fett ist.
Aber das ist kein Fettbike, oder?
Also Cube
hat bei vielen Sachen echt die beste
Preisleistung. Ist auch der größte Hersteller
in Deutschland, was Fahrräder angeht.
Ich glaube,
gefolgt von
Canyon, gefolgt von Rose
oder umgedreht.
Aber ich glaube, so ist richtig.
Cube, Canyon, Rose.
So, dann gucken wir jetzt aber mal,
was auf GitHub trendet.
Um mal zu der eigentlichen Sache wieder zurückzukommen.
Cube hat immer mal Skandalchen.
Ich habe gerade ein schlechtes...
Was da mal durch die Qualitätskontrolle durchrutscht, kann schon sein.
Aber was ich bisher gelesen habe, ist, Cube tauscht da wohl auch immer relativ problemlos aus.
Bei Rose habe ich da tatsächlich jetzt schon öfters mal Beschwerden gelesen, dass es ein Riesenakt mit dem Support war.
Das ist natürlich nicht repräsentativ.
Kann auch sein, dass es bei euch genau umgedreht ist.
Ich kann nur sagen, was ich gelesen habe.
Okay.
Also, gucken wir mal.
Was trennt es denn auf GitHub diese Woche so?
Ich werde wie immer alles, was mit KI ist, überspringen.
AI.
Haben wir schon mal gehabt?
Abseil C++.
AI.
Geil.
Nice Trends diese Woche.
Abseil.
Wisst ihr, an was ich da denken muss jetzt so spontan?
Wenn ich dieses Wort höre.
Moment, ich glaube, wir haben das gar nicht als E-Mail.
Doch.
Irgendwie, wenn ich den Namen lese, denke ich da spontan an...
An den hier.
Und was ist das?
Repository contains
UpSile C++ Library Code.
UpSile is an
Open Source Collection of C++
Code.
Augmented C++
Standard Library.
Okay, und was ist da so zum Beispiel dabei?
Base.
Container.
Flex.
Hash.
Log.
Eine Logging Library.
Memory.
Ich würde jetzt einfach mal reingucken, was man da so sieht.
Strings.
Oh, das ist natürlich immer gut.
Weil Standard String Class in C++ ist halt absoluter Abfuck
Richtig schlecht
Wir gucken uns mal den Source Code an
Ob das hübsches oder ekliges C++ ist
Es ist hyper commentated
Gut, das ist halt Standard ekliges C++ Syntax
Äh
Wer gibt's da nicht
Whatever
B-Tree
B-Tree-Test
B-Tree-Map
Es ist halt C++
Obviusly, was es macht, oder?
Komplett logisch.
Also wer das nicht auf einen Blick erkennt,
was es macht, übelster Kack-Noob.
Jetzt war eine blöde Frage.
Wo ist denn der Source-Code jetzt hier?
Ach hier, okay.
Alter, sieht das hässlich aus.
Oh, das ist noch schön, das C++.
Hä?
Okay, das brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Gibt es da auch irgendwas,
wo Source Code drin ist?
Okay.
C-A-C-C-C-C, da ist Source Code drin.
Static Cast.
C++ ist so hässlich.
Sogar hübsches C++ ist hässlich.
Und das ist doch hübsches C++.
Ah, obviously.
Alles klar.
Schön, Johnny.
Dass du uns das mitteilst.
Sehr erfreut.
dass es bei dir flutscht.
Die F-Alle.
Wenn ich mir das hier angucke.
So, was mich jetzt tatsächlich
noch interessiert, ist Strings.
Was, was, was gibt's da?
Gibt's da irgendwas Sinnvolles?
Viel.
Eine Hilfe-Datei gibt's nicht, okay.
String-Split.
Aber immerhin hat man ein paar gescheite Stringfunctions.
Aber wohl nur für ASCII-Strings, nicht für UTF-8.
Vermutlich.
Beziehungsweise Unicode-Strings.
Naja gut, es ist C++, wen juckt's?
Schauen wir mal weiter, was trendet sonst noch?
Rust
AI, AI
AI
Hatten wir schon, BAM
Es gab letztens noch
einen Post
wie toll der Rust Rewrite ist
Finance Tracker
Rust selbst
DBX
hatten wir auch schon mal
Deno trendet
Biome trendet
das ist so ein Formatter Ding für JavaScript
hast du mal Gaming auf CacheOS probiert?
das ist aber auch nur ein Mini PC
also ich bin mir nicht so sicher
wie weit ich in puncto Gaming
damit komme.
Also ich könnte
irgendwelche Retro-Sachen spielen, ja.
Half-Life 1 oder so.
Das haben wir uns
auch schon mal angeguckt.
AI,
Rust-Desk,
Hat man es auch schon mal angeguckt.
Auch schon angeguckt.
AI.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Juckt mich auch nicht.
So, dann gucken wir mal, was trendet denn bei Go.
Da ist doch meistens halbwegs was Spannendes dabei.
AI.
Argo CD trendet.
Sehr schön.
Beste.
Mag ich.
Argo CD.
Argo CD ist so ein
Deployment Tool
Für Kubernetes, also
Das lässt du in deinem Kubernetes Cluster laufen
Wobei du es nicht zwangsläufig im gleichen Kubernetes Cluster
Laufen lassen musst
Das lässt du im Kubernetes Cluster laufen
Und im Prinzip sagst du
Hier ist ein Repo
Mit Kubernetes
YAML Configs
Argo CD, apply das mal
So und Argo CD sorgt dafür
Dass das immer gesynct wird, also sobald
einer in git was pusht,
synkt Argo CD das in Cluster.
Das war als kurze Übersicht, was Argo CD ist.
Was dazu führt, dass das,
dass quasi der, der Source-Code-Stand
immer möglichst
gleich dem
Cluster-Stand ist.
Eigentlich ein richtig cooles Tool. Haben wir hier im Stream
tatsächlich auch schon mal benutzt vor 2-3 Jahren?
Und was damit gebaut?
Früher gab es noch Flux.
weiß ich auch flugs noch weiterentwickelt wird aber ago cd ist glaube ich mittlerweile so das
verbreitetste tool dafür gott rennt selbst multi docker stellt heads kale tates keck
Das ist nice, dass das parallel trendet.
Terraform trendet.
Haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Terminal File Manager bin ich ja jemand, der sagt, ich weiß nicht wofür.
Prometheus trendet.
Oder sorry, wie der Armin sagt, Prometheus trendet.
Zu Recht.
Beste, beste Metrix-Stells.
Datenbank. Open Code Trended, auch gutes Tool.
Obwohl es AI ist.
Vulnerability Scanner.
Notify.
AI.
Der TypeScript Go Port.
wobei ja auf Reddit manche Leute da immer noch, weiß nicht, Circle-Jerken,
da drüber, warum das ein Go-Port ist und kein Rust-Port.
Aber es ist, wir haben uns ja das Video von Anders Heilsberg angeguckt,
also der C-Sharp und TypeScript-Erfinder,
und er hat im Endeffekt das bestätigt, was ich witzigerweise mir selbst schon gedacht habe.
Also es ist halt deutlich einfacher, Typescript nach Go Zeile für Zeile zu portieren und auch alle Bugs zu behalten.
Und vor allem, Rust hat halt ein großes Problem bei sich selbst referenzierenden Datenstrukturen.
Das funktioniert in Rust nicht richtig, weil es dann halt nicht garantieren kann, zur Compile-Zeit, dass das Memory safe ist.
Go juckt das überhaupt nicht.
Und sowas brauchst du halt für Compiler-Magic.
Ich habe Phone Info gar gelesen.
Phone Info gar.
Was zum...
Drei Jahre, drei Jahre.
Information gathering for telephone numbers.
Aha.
Also man kann public suchen.
AI.
A.I.
Und Compose.
Link lists in Rust.
Ja, genau.
Es geht nicht richtig in Rust.
Es geht immer nur mit Trick 17 und Unsave.
Okay.
Oh, ABAP, Leute.
Was trendet in ABAP?
SAP.
Habe bloß auf nix.
Es trendet nix.
Das ist auch gut, dass da nichts trendet.
Welche Sprache haben wir uns denn noch nie angeguckt,
die uns vielleicht noch interessieren könnte?
Wir haben eigentlich lange nicht mehr getrendet,
geguckt, was in JavaScript trendet.
Das ist natürlich immer ein kompletter Clusterfuck,
was in JavaScript trendet, weil in JavaScript
jede Woche neues Framework
und neue Tools gehypt werden.
Aber trotzdem, gucken wir mal.
AI, AI,
AI,
AI
Nicht AI
Linux Distribution runterladen
Next.js
Prettier
Fastify
Haben wir schon nie gehört
Python haben wir noch gar nicht geguckt
Gucken wir eigentlich sonst nie, können wir aber gucken
AI
Irgendwas hat mich gejuckt
ai es lindt not trendet ai ok moment wir schauen mal kurz in die in die javascript
dinge was das ist html ist ein new markdown levis ist der editor for your html artefakt
moment ist das es ist weib coding kram oder
ist das ein vibe coding?
es ist ein vibe coding
html edit
what the fuck, alter
fastify
das gibt es schon länger
habe ich noch nie gesehen
ok
sieht ein bisschen aus wie fast api
oder sowas, oder flask
oder sowas in python
python
also was
trendet in python
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Keine Ahnung, das haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Ansible.
Damit hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gerechnet, dass ausgerechnet Ansible trendet.
Nice.
Ansible ist quasi das Tun schlechthin, was sich für Serverkonfigurationen durchgesetzt hat.
Ja, man kann damit noch mehr machen, aber hauptsächlich Serverkonfiguration. Es hat natürlich eine gewisse Überschneidung mit Terraform, aber Terraform und Ansible werden eigentlich für zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe eingesetzt.
Terraform wird zum Professionieren von beispielsweise Cloud-Infrastruktur oder generell zum Professionieren, also zum Anlegen von Servern, zum Anlegen von Clustern, zum Anlegen von Storage Buckets, zum Anlegen von Datenbanken, also quasi zum Professionieren von Ressourcen benutzt und Ansible wird dann zum Konfigurieren dieser Ressourcen genutzt.
Es hat ein bisschen Überschneidung, aber man kann ohne Probleme auch beide Tools zusammen anwenden und man sollte auch meiner Meinung nach beide Tools zusammen anwenden.
Also wenn man beispielsweise Terraform-Config hat, 5 Linux-VMs in der Cloud aufzubauen, dann gehört das in Terraform. Da kommen dann so Sachen rein wie welche IP-Range, was für ein Servertyp, Memory Encryption oder nicht, wie viele CPUs, wie viele RAMs, wie viele Festplatten, wie viele SSDs, bla bla, Public IP oder nicht und sonst was hin und her.
also alles mit diesem Betriebssystem drauf und sonst was, also das machst du dann in Terraform
und wenn die Kiste da ist und du den Server dann einrichten willst,
beispielsweise das soll jetzt ein Backend-Server für Java-Applikationen XY werden,
den Server zu konfigurieren, in dem Zustand, wie er sein soll, das machst du dann mit Ansible.
Und das Schöne in Kombination ist, wenn du das automatisiert hast, kannst du
oder wie soll ich sagen,
musst du dich nicht mehr so,
musst du deine Server nicht mehr so pflegen,
ja, also sprich, nicht mehr so,
ich logge mich da drauf jetzt ein,
mach da mal von Hand was,
dann muss ich gucken, dass es auf allen anderen Servern gemacht wird,
wenn du Server relativ schnell neu aufbauen kannst,
in den Zustand bringen kannst,
wie du willst, ist das praktisch,
weil da kannst du sagen, äh, das Ding hat irgendein Problem,
abreiß neu aufbauen.
So, oder ich weiß nicht, was der Typ hier drauf getrieben hat
Abreißen, neu aufbauen
Solange das geht, solange das in ein paar Minuten da ist
Ist überhaupt kein Problem, und das ist in ein paar Minuten da
Also eine VM aufzubauen
Mit Terraform bei Google Cloud zum Beispiel
Das dauert 15 Sekunden
Wenn es die alte VM noch wegschmeißen muss
Vorher, vielleicht ein bisschen länger
15 Sekunden
Und dann läuft Ansible vielleicht
Eine Minute
Das heißt, du hast in knapp
eineinhalb minuten hast du halt neuen server stehen komplett konfiguriert wieder sein soll
das heißt herr form plus ansatz zusammen ist eine gute kombination wenn es nur kleinigkeiten sind
die man konfigurieren muss an dem server kann man natürlich auch terraform machen und gucken
ob man das ganze vielleicht über cloud in it dann auch konfiguriert was natürlich viel nicer
ist wenn man über cloud im cloud in it so einen ansatz beispielsweise konfiguriert dass das server
nach dem aufbau direkt an sie mit pult oder aber man braucht irgendeinen job indem man in in tower
schedule wobei es heißt ja nicht mehr tower das heißt jetzt awx nie ap heißt
das jetzt ja ansible automation plattform
ei ei eine rom manager das haben uns glaube ich schon mal angeguckt für für
alle runtergeladen linux distributionen
Text to Speech, das klingt ja cool.
Machine Learning, LLM, AI, Physics Simulation, AI, AI, AI und Python selber.
Oh, was ist das? Pocket TTS.
A lightweight text-to-speech application designed to run efficiently on CPUs.
Es gibt leider keine...
Es gibt leider keine koreanische und japanische Stimme.
Weil da könnte ich vielleicht...
Mein...
Koreanisches Text to Speech hier ablösen.
Also das hier.
Das ist ja nicht Englisch.
Das ist koreanisches...
Oder japanisches Text to Speech.
Ich habe gedacht, vielleicht gibt es da besonders
weebige Stimmen.
Aber gibt es nicht.
So, das waren die
GitHub-Trends diese Woche.
Habe ich noch irgendeine Sprache vergessen,
die wir uns sonst immer angucken?
Also T++ werde ich mir heute ganz bestimmt nicht angucken.
Da drehe ich durch bei.
Wenn ich mir das mehr als alle
einmal im Monat angucken muss.
Erstmal kurz hier durchscrollen.
Das geht ja.
Charm C.
Okay, komm. Einmal die Hardcore-Variante.
Was trendet denn in C?
Sesamrobot.
Moment.
ESP32-Roboter.
Nice.
Nginx trendet.
John the Ripper trendet.
Passwort.
Hash-Cracking-Stells.
So, Nginx, mein Default-Webserver. Wenn ich nicht irgendeinen anderen Grund habe, was anderes zu verwenden, also einen driftigen Grund, was anderes zu verwenden, verwende ich Nginx.
Weiß nicht, wie es euch da geht, Nginx ist mein Default. Also es gibt eigentlich nur einen anderen Grund, der mir gerade einfällt und das ist, wenn ich was super simples auf einem Public-Webserver mit HTTPS hosten will.
also irgendeine statische Webseite
und ich will einen
HTTPS-Kultivations-
Let's Encrypt-Zertifikat. Dann nehme ich
Kadi. Aber ansonsten nehme ich
immer Nginx. Für alles Nginx.
Nginx, beste.
Weiß nicht, wie es euch da geht.
Jemand von euch noch?
Jemand, der Apache defaultmäßig
verwendet?
Ich kriege ja bei Apache immer ein bisschen
Anfälle.
Also die NGINX-Config ist auch schon ein bisschen undurchsichtig, aber die Apache-Config ist next level.
SAP zwingt dich zu... zu was?
SAP zwingt dich zu Apache, ja? Ist das wirklich so?
Okay, SAP wird... je mehr ich davon lese, umso beschissener, finde ich.
Also hört sich umso beschissener an.
meinung zu traffic also traffic ist nice wenn man die traffic features verwendet ja beispielsweise
wenn man so was wie irgendwie docker compose file hat und mit dem taggen der container automatische
traffic configs erzeugen möchte und so da ist das ganz cool man kann es auch ohne probleme
als Ingress benutzen
oder für Gateway-API,
weil das konfiguriert man dann eher
über die
Kubernetes-Ressourcen
als direkt über Traffic.
Aber ansonsten, ich habe die letzten
Jahre über tatsächlich Abstand von
Traffic genommen. Das liegt
hauptsächlich daran, dass ich die
Config übelst abartig
finde.
Ja.
Sobald man Traffic
von Hand
konfigurieren muss, wird es
eklig. Hier, guckt euch
das an. WTF, Alter?
Was ist das hier, Mann?
Guckt euch das an.
Also von Hand Traffic-Config
ist einfach nur richtig
krass abartig.
Das kann ich, das mag ich überhaupt
gar nicht, ey. So, deswegen
habe ich Abstand von Traffic
genommen und nehme halt einfach Nginx.
Wenn Traffic bei mir im Cluster läuft,
als Ingress oder so, habe ich damit auch keine
schmerzen aber traffic als als nachlicher web server engine x beste
beste
Z-Clip.
Apache trennt auch.
Wie gesagt, Kadi habe ich
gerade gesagt. Achso, du meinst,
du möchtest mir quasi recht geben, dass Kadi für kleine Sachen
nice ist. Ja, ist es.
Ist es. Also so für simple
Dinger wie Public Web
Server, der nur
statisches HTML surft,
Da ist Cuddy die Beste.
Was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Power Toys
React OS
Mach ich einen großen Bogen drum
Wobei es ein cooles Projekt ist
Aber
Also das ist ja quasi
So eine Art Open Source Windows soll das ja sein
Nur das halt im Endeffekt
Also ich den Vorteil nicht so wirklich sehe
Also alles was unter React OS läuft
bzw. 99% was unter ReactOS läuft, läuft auch unter Wine und dann habe ich halt ein echtes Linux.
C4OS.
Ja gut, bringt mir nichts, weil es beim ESP32 halt nicht im Standard SDK dabei ist.
Subred, was ist Subred?
DPI Deep Package Inspection oder?
Fragezeichen.
Nicht Dots per Inch.
Ich glaube mal, dass es Deep Package Inspection ist.
Bypass Multiplattform.
Aha.
Ah, verstehe.
Verstehe.
Gekommen wir jetzt denn am Start?
Okay.
Das ist für die Russen, die keinen Bock haben, getrackt zu werden wahrscheinlich.
Was bei uns ja nie passieren könnte, Leute, dass wir irgendwie überwacht werden im Internet.
Niemals könnte das bei uns passieren, auf gar keinen Fall.
Das ist nur bei den Russen und den China-Chinesen so.
Bei uns nicht.
Und wenn, dann ist es nur zu unserem Besten.
So, das hier können wir zumachen.
Das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich nicht gucken.
Hallo?
Dieser...
Max wieder Overwatch ranked.
Oh ne, ich glaube, das wirst du nicht sehen.
Ich hab, ich hab geistig, ich hab abgeschlossen mit Overwatch.
Ich hab gehört, Overwatch ist jetzt wieder 6 vs 6.
Ist da was dran?
Ist das wirklich so?
Dass sie wieder von 5 vs 5 auf 6 vs 6 umgestellt haben?
Das war nur kurz.
Ah, Sattke.
Weil ich hätte das auch gar nicht gecheckt.
Das ganze Balancing
ging ja um 5 vs 5.
Keine Ahnung.
Gigabyte RAM?
Ja, ich habe noch 8 Gigabyte RAM im Mini-PC.
Das liegt daran, den Rest habe ich im Nass.
So was übrigens immer noch.
Müsst ihr mal kurz hören.
Hier, hört ihr es?
Neben mir steht es noch.
Das ist nass.
Da ist der RAM alles drin.
Und deswegen habe ich hier nur 8 GB RAM drin.
Aber reicht.
8 GB RAM tut.
Okay.
Hermes und Quen.
Endlich wieder alles lokal.
Leute.
Wir haben heute noch kein Video zu KI geguckt.
und uns nicht... Oh, warte, ich muss niesen.
Monka ist...
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal ein Video
zu KI an.
Einmal KI muss sein. Außerdem gucke ich gerne
CT3003 Videos.
Zockst du Overwatch auf Windows?
Ich spiele überhaupt keine Overwatch.
Und wenn, würde ich es wahrscheinlich unter Windows spielen.
Weil ich mir nicht sicher bin, wie gut das
überhaupt läuft unter Linux mit Anti-Cheat und allem.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber ich spiel grad überhaupt kein Overwatch.
Gilt die Chat-Kontrolle auch für KI-Chats?
Naja, bei KI-Chats
ist es egal, ob die gilt oder nicht.
Weil die zeichnen das,
also die können das ja eh schon aufzeichnen
und auswerten, was du da schreibst.
Die Anbieter. Also.
Es hat einer nur im Chat gefragt,
ob ich wieder Overwatch Ranked spiele bald.
Dann hab ich gesagt, naja, ich hab abgeschlossen.
Und mir ist nur aufgefallen, dass die wieder 6 vs 6 haben.
So, schauen wir uns das mal an. Endlich alles lokal.
Ich fänd es sehr geil, wenn es
ähm
Gwent 3.6
hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Wie viel RAM braucht man denn?
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Hugging-Face
Gwen 3.6
Lass mal kurz gucken
Wie viel RAM
Image to Text
Chat bin ich jetzt gerade total verwirrt
Stand da nicht immer dahinter
Wie viel RAM der Kram braucht
Oder check ich es gerade nicht?
Da stand doch...
Da stand doch sonst immer hier irgendwo dabei,
wie viel Ramdas es braucht, oder?
Wie groß das Model ist.
Warum steht das dann nicht mehr dahinter?
Da bin ich jetzt total verblüdet.
Das stand doch hier früher immer
Wie groß das Model ist
Okay, I'll use this Model
In
Äh
Ist das das falsche Format für
Für Ollama oder was?
Warum steht da nicht mehr Ollama drin?
Mach ich jetzt
Ich meine, ich hab's jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mehr verwendet
Aber jetzt bin ich glaube ich
Bin ich glaube ich komplett
Komplett verwirrt
Ah, ja, das habe ich gesucht.
Das habe ich gesucht, genau.
Ja.
Das habe ich gesucht, also.
Das passt leider nicht rein.
Das passt rein.
Das hier könnte ich nehmen.
Oder einfach das hier.
17 Gig
Okay, ja, das würde bei meiner Grafik gerade fonzen
Gucken wir uns das mal an
Obwohl ich mein Internet gerade komplett abgeklemmt habe
Baut mir mein KI-Agent gerade ein Spiel
Das Ding läuft nämlich komplett lokal
Entropic, OpenAI und Co. lesen meine Daten nicht mit
Edgy
Und das Ding kann auch meine Linux-Installation komplett bedienen
Also ich sag eigentlich mit
Edgy
Und das Ding kann auch meine Linux-Installation komplett bedienen.
Also ich sage einfach, such mir mal im Netz irgendwo ein Bild mit irgendwie stricken in Oktopussen und richte mir das als Desktop-Hintergrund ein.
Ja, zack, fertig.
Ich kann aber auch noch viel tiefer ins System gehen und sagen, richte mir mal eine andere Desktop-Umgebung ein.
Ich will Cosmic statt KI.
Das würde ich ehrlich gesagt nicht über die KI machen.
Re, zack, fertig.
Und ihr sagt jetzt vielleicht, ja, das gibt es doch schon lange.
Und dann sage ich, ja, aber nicht in dieser Qualität komplett lokal aufbezahlbare Hardware.
Wir sprechen hier von einem Modell, was auf meiner SSD weniger als 17 GB einnimmt.
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe mir zwar immer gewünscht, dass lokale KI aufholt gegenüber den großen, teuren, energiehungrigen Cloud-Modellen,
die ja auch einfach deaktiviert werden können.
Schöne Grüße an Fable.
Aber ich war auch immer noch ein bisschen skeptisch.
Und jetzt habe ich hier bei mir die Kombination aus dem KI-Agenten Hermes und dem großen Sprachmodell Qen 3.6 27B laufen
und denke jetzt zum allerersten Mal, okay, das will ich so benutzen.
Das macht sinnvolle Dinge.
Und guck mal bitte, wie schnell das antwortet. Das ist Originalgeschwindigkeit.
Ich war zwischendurch so verwirrt von den Fähigkeiten, dass ich gedacht habe, nee, ich glaube, ich habe da doch was falsch konfiguriert.
Der zapft da doch ein Cloud-Modell an. Das kann doch nicht sein.
Und ich habe dann wirklich das Internet...
Ich blicke da langsam nicht mehr durch, was der Unterschied zwischen den ganzen Dingern ist.
Also ich habe ja eine ganze Weile OpenCode verwendet, verwende das immer noch ab und zu.
Dann gibt es Hermes.
Dann gibt es Herder.
Ich blick da mittlerweile nicht mehr durch, was der Unterschied ist.
Leute, ich muss da mein AI-Game
upsteppen, glaube ich.
Und ja, es lief weiter.
Also wirklich komplett lokal.
Ja, aber ich dachte, OpenCode
und Herder ist auch ein Harness.
Ich mach mal kurz noch einen Ticken lauter.
Das ist für mich jetzt wirklich mal wieder
ein revolutionärer Moment,
weil das System wirklich das kann, was ich mir unter agentischer lokaler KI vorstelle.
Hier auch mal schöne Grüße an die kommerziellen Betriebssystemhersteller.
Alles hier im Video ist Open Source und es ist Lichtjahre von dem entfernt, was ihr so macht.
Ja, und leider habe ich später dann auch gemerkt, wo die Kompromisse sind,
die man hier eingehen muss und wo der Haken ist.
Bleibt dran.
Ah, Steam Machine nicht kaufen, ne?
Ne, ne, kauf ich mir nicht.
Ne, das ist ja super toll.
Vor allem, dass...
Äh, wie hieß dieses Ding nochmal?
Nicht Steam Machine, Steam...
Stream Lab?
Ne, äh, Steam Lab?
Ne, äh, das war das von Elgato, ähm...
Wie heißt dieser Handheld nochmal?
Stream Deck!
Stream Deck, genau.
Ne, Stream Deck ist der von Elgato, Steam Deck ist der von Valve, so rum war's.
Äh, meine...
Die Dinger sind ja mittlerweile teurer als zu Release, habe ich gelesen.
Wegen geilen Hardwarepreisen.
Oh ja, das Ding.
Wenn ihr lokale KI macht, dann ist euch vermutlich Sicherheit wichtig.
Und da kommt NordVPN mit seinem Anti-Virus der nächsten Generation.
An der Stelle muss ich immer wieder erzählen, NordVPN wollte bei mir auch mal sponsoren.
und dann hat NordVPN festgestellt,
der Max ist aber
gar nicht so nett zu VPN-Anbietern
und
die haben gesagt, ich soll dieses Video
hier löschen.
Sonst sponsoren sie mich nicht.
Und dann habe ich gesagt,
ich lösche keine Videos, dann sponsort
mich halt nicht.
Tja, Pech gehabt.
Ich meine, ich kann es verstehen, dass die mich nicht sponsern wollen, als jemand, der sich kritisch über VPN-Anbieter äußert.
Kann ich verstehen, ne?
Die können sich ja frei entscheiden, wem sie ihr Geld geben und wem nicht.
Aber ich muss das ja dann auch nicht machen, ne?
Das ist dann auch okay.
So nötig habe ich das nicht.
Genau.
Frankfurt, Goethestraße, Louis Vitor Store, zahl die Kollektion bar.
Fick auf Sponsor.
So sieht es aus.
... die sponsern dieses Video.
Klar, ihr kriegt mit NordVPN schnelles und zuverlässiges VPN
und das auch mit einer No-Log-File-Garantie,
die zum sechsten Mal unabhängig steht.
Aber von wegen Fick auf Sponsor.
Ganz so sehr Fick auf Sponsor kann ich nicht machen.
Will ich auch gar nicht.
Ich muss unbedingt Ukraine und Seagate das Report schicken,
dass ich mein Geld für das Sponsoring,
also für den Sellout im letzten Monat schicke.
Was ich übrigens sehr cool fand, das hat thematisch gut zu meinem Stream gepasst, die Bedingungen waren okay, ähm, ein bisschen mehr Geld hätte es geben dürfen, aber war auch okay.
Das können wir ruhig öfters machen. Und ich glaube für euch war auch ganz okay, oder?
Hetzner, auch mit Hetzner habe ich schon lange keinen Kontakt mehr gehabt.
Und das auch mit einer No-Log-File-Garantie.
No-Log-File-Garantie, ja, die können halt viel sagen.
Das ist halt auch so ein Ding, was ich in meinem Video über VPN-Anbieter gesagt habe.
Das ist alles nur so geil, so lange geil, wie ihr das denen halt glaubt.
Weil die VPN-Anbieter können auf ihrer Seite machen, was sie wollen.
Die können auch euch sonst was erzählen.
Ihr könnt es ja nicht nachprüfen.
Also wenn die sagen, No-Lock-Garantie,
dann sagen die das.
Glaubt ihr das denen? Ja, wenn ihr das glaubt, okay,
wir können das machen. Ob das wirklich so ist, weiß
keiner. Außer die Leute, die das bei
NordVPN eingerichtet haben.
Oh nein, Modcheck,
Leute.
Einmal bitte in Chat.
Einmal bitte in Chat, eine Runde
Modcheck.
Guck mal, er ist neun Jahre
Mod.
Aber du bist nicht bei mir neun Jahre Mod, oder?
So lange bin ich doch noch nicht auf Twitch.
Oder doch? Bin ich schon so lange auf Twitch?
Wirklich?
MonkaS, Alter.
Krass, oder?
Heftig.
Das ist doch scheiße.
Also wie gesagt, No-Lock-Garantie.
Die können euch viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
...sechsten Mal unabhängig bestätigt worden ist.
Ihr bekommt mit dem Antivirus der nächsten Generation aber auch entw...
Wer hat das denn unabhängig bestätigt?
...nicht solides Sicherheitspaket.
Alles in einer App, das zum Beispiel Spam-Anrufe auf einem Handy blockiert.
Es erkennt Phishing, es erkennt Malware.
Und es gibt auch einen Darknet-Monitor, den habe ich neulich mal ausprobiert und der ist echt gruselig.
Der guckt nämlich permanent, ob eure geleakten Daten irgendwo auf Marktplätzen im Darknet auftauchen.
Also, so wie Have I Been Pwned.
Okay, Ecos, das ist eine schöne Erklärung.
Die Bookmarke ich mir mal.
Falls ich mal wieder nicht durchblicke, was für was ist.
Habe ich mir gesaved.
Ich habe ja schon 3 bzw. 4, wenn man den alten HP Microserver mitzählt.
Das reicht erstmal, oder?
Meint ihr nicht, 4 Nasses reichen?
Oder brauchen wir noch mehr?
4 Nasses reicht.
Ach, der Mann.
Oh, scheiße, stimmt, du hast recht.
Ihr kennt mich, Leute.
Ich bin sehr unzuverlässig bei solchen Sachen.
Und es war kein Fake.
Ich hatte wirklich vor, dem das zu schicken.
Sonst hätte ich da gar nicht gesagt.
Aber ich habe mit meinen Nassexperimenten hier einfach nicht weitergemacht daheim.
Und weiß immer noch nicht, welches Nass ich verwende.
Aber mit mehr Daten.
Probiert NordVPN nochmal aus.
Mit unserem Code CT3003 gibt es vier extra Monate obendrauf.
Und das Ganze mit 30 Tagen Geld-Zurück-Garantie.
Werbung Ende.
Sag mal, wenn es 30 Tage Geld-Zurück-Garantie gibt.
und man sich ja da bestimmt nicht mit Telefonnummer und so registrieren muss,
kann ich mir nicht einfach beliebig viele Fake-E-Mail-Adressen machen
und immer bei NordVPN 30 Tage ausnutzen und sagen, ich will Geld zurück?
Das System ausgetrickst?
Wahrscheinlich funktioniert das aber nicht, weil die 30-Tage-Geld-Zurück-Garantie
bestimmt nur mit komischen Auflagen ist.
So scanne deinen Personalausweis ein und so.
Das macht dann keiner.
Die verifizieren über die Bankdaten.
Moment.
Warum verifizieren die überhaupt?
Ist das nicht komplett entgegengesetzt dem?
Ey, das ist doch komplett entgegengesetzt dem,
was die erzählen.
Die erzählen das alles krass anonym.
Und dann wirst du verifiziert über die Bankdaten.
Geil.
sehr schön
kann man wenigstens anonym oder anonym ist es ja nicht um zwangsläufig aber
kann man dann wenigstens über über crypto währung bezahlen
das muss jetzt mal kurz kommen kann man nord vpn über crypto stellt crypto
crypto payment bargeld ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht also ich denke mir
das jetzt aus sicht von leuten von leuten die die damit wirklich etwas
anstellen wollen ja sagt ich verwende schon seit jahren kein torrent zeug mehr
oder sonstige sachen zum linux distribution runterladen und ich habe
auch seit jahren kein vpn mehr verwendet weil wenn ich mir irgendwas runterlade
dann ist es halt normales zeug und alles andere gucke ich über irgendwelche
streaming anbieter wenn ich was runter also die sachen die
mich die ich mir runter lassen tatsächlich sachen die man sich
runterladen darf und filme und so zeug lade ich mir überhaupt nicht mehr runter
das gucke ich mittlerweile einfach was gibt es bei den streaming anbietern wenn
es das nicht gibt gucke ich halt nicht
You can pay with
Cryptocurrencies, kann man, okay
Paypal sofort, Bank oder Local
Bank Transfers, Prepaid
Debit Card
Okay
Mit welchen, mit welchen Krypto-Stells
kann man denn
bezahlen, was akzeptieren
die denn da?
Weiß man nicht.
Steht da nicht da.
Ist es nur Bitcoin oder so was anderes?
egal guck mal das video
ich habe keine mit korn also meine investitionsstrategie ist ganz einfach
einfach alles in world etf fertig oder fast alles fast alles was das
Geld zurück Garantie.
Werbung Ende.
Ja Leute, also zwei Sachen schreibt ihr uns ständig in die Kommentare.
Macht doch mal was zu Hermes Agent und macht doch bitte mal mehr über lokale KI-Modelle.
Und ja, das machen wir jetzt. Und sogar beides in einem Video, in diesem hier nämlich.
Und ich versuche jetzt mal wirklich alle von euch abzuholen, weil ich auch wirklich finde, dass das, was hier jetzt möglich ist, wirklich für alle...
Ich weiß nicht genau, was es ist.
Dass ich irgendwo einen wahrscheinlich
saumäßig wertvollen
CS-Skin
oder was es da alles gibt,
Messer oder so, keine Ahnung.
Aber,
ich weiß aber nicht wo,
weil ich war ja mal auf
in Köln.
Ich war mal auf einem CS-Major in Köln
So, ich weiß nicht mehr, wann das war
Das ist schon eine ganze, ganze Weile her
Ich weiß es nicht
Ich hab mir damals an so einem Stand
So einen Pin geholt
Hier, 2015
war das.
So, und das kann man ja irgendwie einlösen.
Und ich hab keine Ahnung,
was das ist. Mein Problem ist,
ich weiß nicht, wo ich's hab.
Ich hab so eine Kiste, so eine große Kiste,
wo mein gesamtes
Merchandising-Zeug
drin liegt.
Und da liegt auch,
dachte ich, irgendwo dieser
Kieb drin, aber
letztens mit einem drüber geredet
und der hat auch gemeint, boah Max, das müsste wahrscheinlich
voll viel wert sein,
aber ich hab's dann nicht mehr gefunden.
Ja.
Ah, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das mit...
Relevant ist, die gerne mal einen Computer benutzen.
Das Video ist so aufgebaut, dass es erstmal eher allgemein ist und dann zum Ende dann doch ein bisschen nerdig wird.
Weil das Thema lokale KI ist halt noch etwas fummelig, aber es lohnt sich auch wirklich.
Also erstmal ganz grob, was ist Hermes Agent überhaupt? Ja, das ist ein KI-Agent und anders als ein Chatbot wie chatgpt.com, das halt wirklich nur im Browser-Fenster lebt und mir da halt Text und vielleicht Bilder zurückgibt, kann so ein Agent selbst Dinge tun, also mir die komplette Computerbedienung abnehmen.
Das heißt, ich kommuniziere mit dem Agenten in normaler Menschensprache, entweder...
Also ich hab das in OpenCode bei mir so gemacht,
ich hab dem
erstmal alle Bash-Commands
verboten auszuführen,
außer ein paar sind erlaubt.
Ich hab keinen Bock,
dass mein Agent da irgendwelche Dinger treibt.
Deswegen wäre
wahrscheinlich für mich noch besser,
anstatt OpenCode lokal
auf meiner Linux-Kiste auszuführen,
das in einer extra VM oder zumindest mal in einem extra
Container auszuführen.
Da kann er nicht viel kaputt machen.
Per Kommandozeile oder auch per Sprachnachricht. Ich kann den nämlich auch an eine Messenger-App auf dem Smartphone ankoppeln und sage dem dann, was ich will oder was ich machen will.
Und dann macht er das. Das können Programmierprojekte sein, zum Beispiel dieser Schneemann-Shooter hier.
Was ist...
Was ist... Da kann man danach... Moment, kann man danach googeln?
Ich glaube schon.
BW-Rap.
Ups.
What the fuck?
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Chat!
Wie habe ich das überhaupt geöffnet?
Bubble-Rap.
Applications in the Sandbox.
Okay.
Ich könnte es auch einfach im Container laufen lassen.
Wobei Container Escape ist real, ne?
Aber ich monte ja da nichts Rootfile-Systemmäßiges rein.
Mal gucken.
Erstmal Video schauen.
Ich würde ein Cloud-Modell entwickeln lassen.
Oder halt auch einfach Computer-Problemlösungen.
Wie zum Beispiel, ich kriege Comfy UI hier auf meiner AMD-Hardware nicht zum Laufen.
Installier mir das mal bitte.
Oder guck dir mal alle Bilder in diesem Ordner an und verschiebe alle YouTube-Thumbnails in Unterordner XY.
Also alles, was ein Mensch so machen könnte, der Zugriff auf diesen Computer hat, auf dem Hermes Agent läuft.
Am besten funktioniert das mit Dingen, die man im Terminal, also auf der Kommandozeile machen kann, also textbasiert.
Mit grafischen Benutzeroberflächen und Websites kann Hermes Agent auch arbeiten, aber bei weitem nicht so gut.
Agenten denken halt in Text und deshalb können sie am besten mit Text umgehen.
Hermes Agent läuft auf Linux, MacOS und Windows und man kann es nicht nur auf der Kommandozeile verwenden, sondern es gibt auf Wunsch auch eine grafische Benutzeroberfläche, die sieht so aus.
Ich habe im Rest dieses Videos Hermes aber über die Kommandozeile bzw. über den Telegram Messenger bedient.
Falls euch das jetzt bekannt vorkommt, ja genau, das gilt auch alles für OpenClaw, der Hype-Software aus Österreich.
Der Hype, ich würde sagen, der Hype ist schon wieder ein bisschen abgeklungen um OpenClaw, oder?
In den USA, der Entwickler Peter Steinberger arbeitet ja inzwischen bei OpenAI.
OpenClaw ist zwar offiziell kein OpenAI-Projekt und bleibt Open Source,
aber naja, viele Leute sehen die Software seit Steinbergers OpenAI-Gang ein bisschen skeptisch.
Ja, und deswegen jetzt Hermes Agent, das ist eine Alternative, ist auch Open Source,
gleiche Lizenz, MIT und man muss aber wirklich sagen, dass sich die beiden schon wirklich sehr, sehr ähneln.
Meine Erfahrung ist, Hermes arbeitet vielleicht ein bisschen autonomer,
Autonomer kriegt Sachen besser selbstständig hin.
Bei OpenClaw muss man öfter hin und her gehen.
Also sowas wie, versuch's bitte nochmal, so und so.
Hermes ist da oft hartnäckiger.
Und Hermes ist auch mehr auf Tokensparsamkeit optimiert.
Tokens, das ist ja die kleinste Einheit mit der große...
Ich dachte, Hermes ist ein Logistikunternehmen.
Sprachmodelle arbeiten, das sind quasi Silben.
Und das Ding bei diesen Agenten ist halt, dass die hinter den Kulissen einfach mit riesigen Prompts arbeiten.
Also da steht dann halt ein riesiger Roman drin, was sie gerade alles beachten müssen.
Und deshalb verbrauchen Agenten mies viel Tokens.
Das ist gut für Unternehmen wie Entropic und OpenAI, die halt Tokens verkaufen.
Das ist nicht so gut für Leute, die Agenten benutzen und Tokens kaufen müssen.
Deshalb ist es ja auch so cool, dass ich hier komplett lokal arbeiten kann.
Ich habe letztens einen Post gesehen von einem Entwickler, der Programmiervideos macht auf YouTube.
der hat letztens ein Screenshot gepostet, seine Cloud Code Tokens oder seine Anthropic Tokens.
Und der hat, glaube ich, 23.000 Dollar ausgegeben schon diesen Monat.
Also die sind da teilweise echt total übertrieben drauf.
Ich bezahle also nur, weil da hat er meinen Strom, aber keine Tokens. Dazu später mehr.
Kurz mal technisch zum Unterschied zwischen Hermes und OpenCore.
Hermes verwendet intern am liebsten Python, um Sachen zu skripten, OpenClaw TypeScript, das ist eine JavaScript-Geschmacksrichtung. Außerdem bezeichnet Hermes sich als permanent selbst...
Soll ich euch mal sagen, wo ich denke, dass der Unterschied zwischen einem Vibe-Coder und einem, wie nennen wir den, nicht Vibe-Coder, Programmierer, Entwickler, Softwareentwickler liegt.
Der Unterschied zwischen einem Vibe-Coder und einem Softwareentwickler.
Ist das vielleicht ein bisschen philosophisch gedacht?
aber ich würde sagen
dem Softwareentwickler
geht es
also ich meine jetzt
wohlgemerkt, muss ich sagen
die
innere Motivation der Leute
das zu machen, ja, also was ist
quasi die innere Motivation des Vibe-Coders
zu Vibe-Coden und was ist die innere
Motivation des Softwareentwicklers, Software zu
entwickeln, so
Bei einem hauptberuflichen Softwareentwickler will er natürlich Geld verdienen, aber das ist bei einem Vibe-Coder vielleicht auch. Das meine ich gar nicht. Also ich bin der Meinung, ein Softwareentwickler, dem geht es beim Programmieren oder beim Softwareentwickeln gar nicht so sehr primär nur um das Ergebnis, was rauskommt, sondern er möchte verstehen, wie es funktioniert.
Also dem geht es ein bisschen so um den, nennen wir es mal Erkenntnisgewinn oder so.
Einem Vibe-Coder wiederum geht es überhaupt nicht ums Verstehen, sondern nur um das Ergebnis, was rauskommt am Ende.
Also ein Vibe-Coder ist dadurch motiviert, dass am Ende sowas rauskommt in der Richtung, wie er sich vorgestellt hat.
Und ein Entwickler zieht seine Motivation und Spaß daraus, dass er versteht, was passiert. Und dem ist das Ergebnis, sagen wir mal, nur so semi-wichtig. Also ich habe schon auch viele Projekte gestartet, wo ich sehr viel gelernt habe und happy war am Ende und es ist nichts Sinnvolles dabei rausgekommen.
Das würde einen Vibe-Coder total demotivieren.
Da hat er überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Vibe-Coder will Ergebnisse, Programmierer oder Softwareentwickler, dem geht es eigentlich
ums Verstehen.
Das ist so meine Meinung, der Unterschied zwischen Softwareentwickler und reinem Vibe-Coder.
Natürlich überlagert sich das alles ein bisschen.
Würdet ihr das auch so sehen oder würdet ihr sagen, klingt nachvollziehbar?
Oder war das jetzt zu High IQ für so früh am Tag?
Aber Dipbox, ist das für dich wirklich dein Antrieb, weshalb du das machst?
Also ja, dass du das machst, um Geld zu verdienen und so, das kann ich alles verstehen.
Aber wenn du privat für dich was entwickelst, geht es dir dann eher darum, dass du das Problem verstanden hast?
Oder was gelernt hast und die Technik verstanden hast?
Oder geht es dir nur um das, was rauskommt?
Ja, dass man das auf der Arbeit macht, kann ich verstehen.
Ich kann nur sagen, wie das bei mir ist.
Also mir geht es hauptsächlich darum, dass ich das verstehe.
Ja, erinnert ihr euch noch dran, wir haben vor Jahren mal ein WebAssembly Video Player programmiert in C++.
WebAssembly Video Player, der Videos abspielen konnte in Formaten, die der Browser normalerweise nicht kann.
Und da ist am Ende nie was wirklich Sinnvolles bei rausgekommen.
Ich war aber trotzdem super zufrieden, weil ich sehr viel gelernt habe über WebAssembly und wie das alles so funktioniert.
Um die Lösung, ja, meine ich ja auch.
Aber die geht jetzt nicht primär darum, dass am Ende deine App-Idee XY rauskommt, egal wie.
Würde dir widersprechen, viele auf der Arbeit haben, ja gut, 90% der Leute sacken eh.
Mir ging es jetzt weniger um die Arbeit, sondern was die Leute eben tatsächlich, wenn sie privat was programmieren oder motiviert das zu machen.
Das machen die Leute, die keinen Bock auf die Sache haben, ja eh nicht.
So, aber lang genug drüber rumphilosophiert
Wir gucken jetzt erstmal das Video weiter, weil ansonsten
sehe ich da schon schwarz, dass wir das
irgendwie schaffen heute
Ah ja, gut
Ja, wir Vibe-Administraten
ja auch öfters im Stream, so ist das nicht
Ich glaube, es vergeht kaum irgendwie einen Stream, wo wir was basteln, Technik-Kram machen, wo wir nicht zumindest ein bisschen KI-Zeug mittlerweile drin haben.
Guck mal, gestern, ich habe gestern auch laufend Chat-GPT nach RabbitMQ-Commands und so gefragt, weil wer weiß den Scheiß schon aus dem Kopf?
Das ist ja mittlerweile normal, dass du das als Unterstützung verwendest.
Das heißt, dass es sich automatisch Sachen merkt, wenn es was gut hinbekommen hat.
Zum Beispiel, wie man bestimmte Werkzeuge konkret aufruft.
Und es baut auch selbst solche Werkzeuge. Selbstständig.
Das kann OpenClaw auch, macht es aber laut meiner Erfahrung nicht ganz so zuverlässig.
Also das kann sein, dass sich OpenClaw einen abbricht.
Wenn lokale LMMs mittlerweile APU-Grafik-Heilheiten der APU-Folge...
Ja, ja, ja. Das haben wir sogar hier schon ausprobiert.
Wobei hier bin ich mir nicht sicher.
aber auf dem NAS haben wir das ausprobiert
und das NAS hat die gleiche
GPU, das hat funktioniert
jaja
wir hatten Ulama
und in Ulama
mussten wir dann
irgendeinen Parameter setzen
ich weiß gar nicht mehr welchen, wir mussten
und dann haben wir mit NVTop geguckt
und die CPU hatte
die GPU hatte Auslastung
wenn ein Ola-Ma läuft. Das hat funktioniert.
Das war sogar gar nicht so lahm.
Also wir haben das auf dem
Minis-Forum nass gemacht.
Was hatten wir da am Ende?
Weiß ich nicht.
10 Talkens oder so?
10, 12 Talkens die Sekunde?
Das war komplett usable,
wenn man ein bisschen Zeit hat.
Zum Beispiel in meinem Heimnetzwerk
irgendwie Inhalte auf meinen Fernseher zu bringen
Und wenn man das dann später nochmal versucht, dann fängt er manchmal wieder von vorne an,
statt sich an die schon mal gefundene Lösung zu erinnern, was super nervig sein kann.
Bei Hermes ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit höher, dass es sich gemerkt hat, wie mein Fernseher ansprechbar ist.
Dafür hat OpenClaw aber mehr vorgefährdete Skills in der eigenen Claw-Hub-Datenbank.
Hermes schreibt sich die Skills lieber selbst.
Und was auch ganz klar sichtbar ist, Hermes Agent verhält sich technischer als OpenClaw.
Also Hermes zeigt auch mal irgendwelche Terminal-Aufrufe im Messenger,
Während Open Claw solche Sachen...
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wetter IN geht doch gar nicht mehr, oder?
Doch!
Geht wieder!
Exzellent!
Nice!
Es geht wieder. Oh, guck mal.
Leute, Standort-Leak.
Koordinaten.
Mal gucken, wo ich bin.
Ob ich wieder in Main wohne oder so.
Da gab es doch irgendwie...
Wie konnte man bei Maps
nochmal Koordinaten eingeben?
Ah, hier. Ah, ja.
Okay, heute wohne ich nicht in Main.
Heute wohne ich mitten auf dem Marktplatz in Hanau.
Okay.
Auch gut. Leaked, Leute.
liegt. Ja.
Vielleicht liege ich auch gerade im Krankenhaus.
Aber Wetter.in geht wieder. Das ist nice.
Terminal-Aufrufe im Messenger,
während OpenClaw solche Sachen
eher versteckt und versucht, einen Menschen
zu cosplayen. Und OpenClaw
ist als privates Hobbyprojekt gestartet,
wo es halt null um Security und
sowas ging. Das hat sich inzwischen auf jeden Fall
verbessert. Anscheinend ist in der Schweiz
das ein bisschen breiter, wie die
IPs verteilen und so.
Das macht es ja nur anhand von meiner IP fest,
wo ich wohne.
Aber ganz klar, bei Hermes Agent
wurde Security von Anfang an mitgedacht.
Einfach weil es das
neuere Projekt ist. Hinter Hermes
steckt News Research aus New York.
Die kommen aus der Kryptowelt und sind
schon lange in der lokalen LLM-Szene
aktiv, haben zum Beispiel unzensierte
Modelle veröffentlicht. Das ist eine recht kleine
Firma, also noch jedenfalls.
Okay, das erstmal vorab. Und wie genau
habe ich Hermes Agent jetzt getestet?
Also natürlich habe ich das nicht auf einem
Produktivsystem installiert, wo irgendwelche
wichtigen Daten drauf sind. Hermes hat
nämlich Zugriff aufs ganze System. Da können
also Sachen kaputt gehen. Das Thema
Der Chat sagt, CT ist gar nicht so
cool informiert über Hermes. Wieso? Was stimmt nicht?
Gänste Systeme ist ja auch noch ziemlich neu.
Ich persönlich würde euch deshalb
immer empfehlen, probiert das nur
auf Systemen auf, wo es nicht schlimm wäre, wenn a alle Daten verloren...
Ja, das ist klar.
Also gut, es gibt Leute, die sind so bescheuert, installieren sich das auf ihrem Standard Windows PC.
Nee, nee, das will ich nicht machen.
Und b wenn die Daten von diesem Rechner irgendwo hin abfließen.
Stichwort Prompt Injections, also versteckte Anweisungen an den Agenten,
die irgendwo im Netz liegen können.
Deshalb habe ich es so gemacht, dass ich Hermes Agent auf einem komplett blanken System getestet habe.
in dem Fall CacheOS, also Linux, und das auf einem Framework Desktop.
Das ist ein Rechner, der selbst auch zusätzlich zu Hermes in LLM hosten kann,
also auf dem nicht nur Hermes selbst läuft, sondern eben auch das lokale LLM-Auffund, wenn ich das will.
Das muss aber nicht so sein, denn Hermes selbst läuft auch auf einem sehr viel langsameren Rechner.
Das kann ein altes Notebook sein oder ein gemieteter VPS
oder man kann das Ding auch in der virtuellen Maschine installieren, ist alles egal.
Wenn ihr aber keine Cloud-KI nutzen wollt, dann braucht ihr dann aber halt noch einen Rechner, auf dem ein LLM läuft.
Und dann braucht ihr eine Grafikkarte und eine Grafikkarte mit viel RAM und das ist aktuell ziemlich teuer.
Für mich ist der Sweetspot...
Wobei ich ja sagen muss, ich habe letztens jetzt schon öfters mal gelesen, dass Unternehmen sagen, Tokens sind ihnen zu teuer geworden.
Sie stellen Leute ein, weil echte Leute wieder billiger geworden sind als Tokens.
Das ist echter Wahnsinn aktuell.
In Sachen Qualität und Aufwand zur Zeit
Qen 3.6 mit 27 Milliarden Parametern.
Ah, das ist das Model, was wir auch gerade hatten, stimmt's?
Das hatten wir auch gerade.
In 4-Bit-Quantisierung.
Da sind die Gewichte 17 Gigabyte ungefähr groß.
Also man braucht dann also mit...
Aber Nvidia sagt uns doch,
Tokens gleich Profit.
Und mit Kontext und mit Sicherheit.
Und Nvidia sagt auch, wenn ein Entwickler, der 150.000 Dollar verdient, nicht mindestens nochmal 150.000 Dollar an Tokens ausgibt, dann taugt da nix.
Reserve ungefähr 24 Gigabyte schnellen Speicher. Im besten Fall GPU-Speicher. Zu Not läuft das aber auch.
Ich meine, an der Nvidia-Stelle würde ich das auch erzählen.
auf 24 GB normalen RAM.
Bei meinem Test habe ich
Quen von einem Gaming-PC
mit RTX 4090
auf meinen Linux-Hermes-Rechner.
Bin ich froh, dass ich mir damals
64 GB RAM und eine
fette 4090 gekauft habe.
Wenn ich das so gemacht hätte wie früher,
ähm, wenn ich das so gemacht hätte
wie früher,
dann, Moment, warum werden
Sachen gelöscht. Muss mal kurz gucken, was da los ist.
Ach, das.
Den hättest du
tatsächlich nicht löschen müssen.
Das haben wir sogar schon mal geguckt.
Jetzt hab ich vergessen,
was ich sagen wollte.
Zugespielt, gesurft sozusagen.
Übrigens, lief auf dem LLM-Rechner.
Ach so, genau, dass ich hier 64 GB
und 4090 gekauft hab damals.
Hätte ich es so gemacht wie früher, dass ich gesagt hätte, ey, ich kaufe mir mal ein bisschen was preis-leistungsmäßig Gutes und in zwei Jahren oder einem Jahr packe ich mir vielleicht dann noch eine neuere Grafikkarte rein, dann wäre ich jetzt voll gearscht gewesen.
Also es war gut
Dass ich mir einen 5K 5000 Euro Rechner
Damals gekauft hab
Mit 4090, 64GB
24 Kerne CPU
Und alle möglichen Krempel
Und was ich witzig finde ist
Der Rechner war damals
Mega High End
Und der ist jetzt 3,5 Jahre später
Immer noch High End
Das gibt, das kann sich eigentlich keinem erzählen
Das hat es früher nicht gegeben
Die nutzt du bestimmt voll aus.
Nee, die eidelt größtenteils rum und langweilt sich.
Und wenn ich was spiele, ist das aktuell meistens irgendwelches uralte Zeug,
was weder Multicore noch neue GPU-Sachen ausnutzen kann.
Also Linux wird von Windows gesurft.
Aber bevor wir in die Details einsteigen,
einsteigen, also wie man das Ding lokal einrichtet.
Ein paar Beispiele, was ich mit der Kombination Hermes und Quen 3.6 27B so gemacht habe.
Erstmal ganz allgemein zum Verständnis, denn auch wenn das LLM selbst nicht ins Internet kann,
kann es Hermes und das ist eine gute Kombination.
Also Intelligenz vom lokalen Modell und Internet vom argentischen System.
Da kann man dann nämlich einfach auch so Sachen fragen, wie ist das Wetter zurzeit in Hannover
und dann gibt es darauf eine Antwort.
Und die Systeme halluzinieren dann auch nicht mehr so viel,
weil es sich eben immer mundgerecht Informationen aus dem Internet holen kann.
Weil Hermes eben nicht nur über die Kommandozeile steuerbar ist,
habe ich auch mein Handy verwendet mit Telegram.
Nicht, weil ich so ein Telegram-Fan bin,
sondern weil Telegram am einfachsten einzurichten ist mit solchen Agenten.
Das dauert mit Telegram wirklich nur drei Sekunden.
Damit kann ich dann den Hermes-Agent auch von unterwegs verwenden,
ohne dass ich mein internes Netz irgendwie nach draußen öffnen muss.
geht wie gesagt alles über telegram im detail habe ich das ja schon im openclor video gezeigt
ja mein erster praktischer test ob es hermes mit dem lokalen quen schafft hier im browser
meine jährlichen mitarbeiter schulungen zu lösen das sind so multiple choice fragen und da sind
wir dann schon direkt im territorium das recht anschaulich zeigt warum man lokale modelle
verwenden will da habe ich nämlich deutlich weniger bauchschmerzen so firmeninterne website
Ja gut, ja, auch kein Verstehen.
Bleibt ja schließlich alles auf meiner eigenen Hardware.
Würde ich jetzt OpenAI oder Entropic Cloud verwenden, würde halt ganz viel Zeug an US-Server geschickt werden.
Will ich nicht.
Hier geht es zwar jetzt nur um so eine Sicherheitsschulung, die auch nicht direkt im heißen Intranet läuft,
sondern auf einer externen Website.
Also Firmengeheimnisse gibt es da eh nicht.
Aber fühlt sich halt trotzdem deutlich besser an, weil halt alle Daten auf meinen Rechnern bleiben.
Aber es geht ja nicht nur um mein Gefühl.
Viele von euch sind ja auch beruflich an irgendwelche Zertifizierungen gebunden.
Und da gibt es viele, die zum Beispiel verbieten, dass Daten außerhalb der EU verarbeitet werden.
Und ja, da habt ihr dann ein Problem mit Cloud und so.
Ich will aber jetzt auch nicht sagen, hey, mit lokalen Modellen ist das alles gar kein Problem.
Also eure Daten werden natürlich nicht direkt irgendwo zu Drittanbietern geschickt,
wo die Daten dann womöglich noch irgendwie zum Modelltraining oder so verwendet werden.
Aber es besteht immer die Gefahr, dass euer Agent, wenn er eine Netzanbindung hat,
über vergiftete Prompts irgendwo stolpert und womöglich Dinge tut, die ihr gar nicht machen sollt.
Bedenkt das immer mit, wenn ihr wirklich Dinge verarbeiten wollt, die auf keinen Fall jemand sehen darf,
dann benutzt eure Agentionsysteme komplett ohne Internetverbindung.
Das geht schon auch.
Bei meinen Tests hier hat es allerdings immer eine Verbindung nach außen
und mir sind auch keine Prompt-Injections untergekommen, zumindest nicht bewusst.
Ja, und wie ist Hermes jetzt klargekommen mit den Schulungen, mit den Tests?
Also am Ende hat es alle Prüfungen erfolgreich bestanden,
Aber der Weg dahin war extrem umständlich.
Ich hatte ja gerade schon gesagt, dass es auf dem Terminal echt besser funktioniert als auf Websites, weil es da wirklich...
Ich würde Zustände kriegen, wenn mein Terminal so durchsichtig ist.
Da erkenne ich gar nichts richtig.
Ich immer Screenshots machen muss, ans LLM schicken, analysieren, gucken, wo es hinklicken muss und so weiter.
Und das verbraucht halt extrem viele Tokens, was also dann dazu geführt hat, dass Hermes ständig den Kontextspeicher,
also quasi das aktuelle Kurzzeitgedächtnis, komprimieren musste.
Das Problem hatte ich tatsächlich auch. Ich habe mal eine Zeit lang, Quencoder, was war das, Quencoder 3.5 oder so, habe ich laufen lassen mit LM Studio und mit Ulama und der ist permanent an das Limit gekommen von seinem Zwischenspeicher.
Und das dauert und macht auch die Arbeit nicht unbedingt besser, sage ich mal.
Hermes hat also super oft neu angesetzt, obwohl es eigentlich schon fast fertig war.
Es hat dann auch irgendwelche Skripte geschrieben, um das Kontextproblem zu lösen.
Und ja, es tat schon wirklich ziemlich weh, das als Mensch zu beobachten, wie es sich da abgequält hat.
Aber hey, aber am Ende hat es, wie gesagt, irgendwie geklappt.
Viel besser haben Sachen funktioniert, die sowieso komplett übers Terminal gingen.
Also sowas wie installiere A-Step zur Musikgenerierung, generiere ein Lied über fliegende Oktopusse und spiele das auf meiner Sonos-Box ab.
Und zwar...
Was ist NTSync? Das kenne ich noch gar nicht.
Ist das sowas wie Looking Glass oder sowas? NTSync?
Was ist NTSync? NTSync ist ein Linux-Kernel-Modul, das die Prozess-Synchronisationsmechanismen des Windows-NT-Kernels direkt auf Betriebssysteme nachbildet.
Was ist NTSync?
Bin ich zu dumm für?
Check ich nicht.
Da bin ich zu low IQ für.
Natürlich ohne, dass ich Hermes mehr Details gegeben hätte.
Der schafft das einfach.
Der findet die Sonos-Box im Netzwerk und findet raus, wie man das darauf abspielt.
Und macht das einfach.
Ja, und Coding geht natürlich auch.
Hier ein Spiel, wo man mit Warmwasser Schneemänner und Frauen zum Schmelzen bringt.
Ich glaube, das hatte mit der Hitzewelle zu tun, dass ich auf die Idee gekommen bin.
Und hier der 3003 Cyber Run, wo man mit diesem tollen Auto rumfährt und komischen Dingern ausweicht.
Was ich hier beeindruckend fand, die Soundeffekte hat Hermes einfach lokal mit dem Tool Hardmula generiert.
Und ich hatte Hardmula gar nicht selbst installiert oder installieren lassen.
Mit was für einem Tool? Hardmula? Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Und klar, Hermes kann auch in Linux rumfrickeln, zum Beispiel mein Desktop-Hintergrundbild ändern
und das Bild vorher auch lokal mit ComfyUI und zum Beispiel dem Bildgenerierer Flux generieren.
Hier ein Oktopus vorm Rechner.
Also ich kann wirklich sagen, ich hätte gerne das und das auf meinem Desktop-Hintergrundbild und das war's.
Das macht er dann.
Und das kann ich auch in mein Handy reinlabern als Sprachie.
Und das, wie gesagt, komplett lokal, ohne dass Daten von mir irgendwo rausgehen.
Ehrlich gesagt stelle ich mir genau so einen persönlichen Copiloten vor
und kurioserweise hat das von den großen Betriebssystementwicklern noch niemand geschafft.
Das ist alles hier Open Source.
arm eigentlich, dass sie da nicht mehr hingekriegt haben.
Also es ist nicht arm, CPUs.
Sondern es ist arm.
Aber ja klar, das funktioniert zwar,
aber das ist auch noch nichts für den
Massenmarkt. Könnt ihr zum Beispiel hier sehen,
als ich gesagt habe, er soll
ein weiteres Desktop-Environment installieren.
Mein Cache-iOS hatte bis dahin nur
KDE installiert und ich wollte Cosmic.
Ja, das ging jetzt
nur so halb gut, aber hey,
am Ende hat es dann auch geklappt.
Aber auch wenn Hermes mit Quen auf der Kommandozeile und beim Coding ganz gute Resultate abliefern, sieht das beim Sprachgefühl eher nicht so gut aus.
Also wie es mit mir kommuniziert, da merke ich dann schon, dass das kein Mensch ist.
Hier habe ich zum Beispiel gerade versucht, per Telegram meinen LLM-Server zu benchmarken.
Dann sagt Hermes mit Quen so zu mir, ich schicke eine Anfrage und timings sie selbst.
Ich dann so, was? Timings sie selbst? Und dann sagt das System, ah guter Punkt, das war schwul formuliert.
Ich so, wie schwul.
Antwort, haha, okay, fair.
Ich meinte es eher als umständlich formuliert oder schlecht ausgedrückt.
Lach, wein, Emoti.
Also keine Ahnung, aber das Ding irgendwie mit Klotüren-Sprüchen,
die aus den 90ern trainiert wurde.
Aber schwul für schlecht, das ist schon ziemlich hängen geblieben.
Und weil das eben so ein vergleichsweise kleines Sprachmodell ist,
neigt es auch zu starken Halluzinationen, vor allem ohne Internetzugang.
Hier sind zum Beispiel 20 Attraktionen in Hannover, die in keinem Reiseführer stehen.
Und jede einzelne ist komplett zu 100% halluziniert.
Aber zugegebenermaßen sind die auch ziemlich unterhaltbar.
Leibnitzens letzter Hausschuh.
Leibnitzens letzter Hausschuh im Historischen Museum.
Vitrine 14b.
Hannovers erste Telefonzelle, die in einer Hauswand steckt und heute ein Briefkasten ist.
Ja, klar, logisch.
Oder Hannoversche Himmelstürmer-Ecke.
Daneben ein fast unsichtbarer...
ein fast unsichtbarer gummi das grüne herz vermutende skulptur eine vergessene umwelt
installation aus recycelten fahrrädern im stadt ist ja und das ist das das ist teilweise so das
fatale an diesen halluzinationen die lesen sich dazwischen dann euch mal vor langen text damit
das liest du dann einfach so und es klingt das klingt so plausibel passt schon passt schon
überlegt jetzt und man hier ist es jetzt noch relativ klar überlegt euch mal ihr bekommt
irgendeine 50 seitige arbeit die mit chat gpt oder irgendeinem anderen model erstellt wurde
und ihr müsst da das sinnvolle und das halluzinierte irgendwie auseinander
basteln das ist ganz erknicken garten die langsam rosti und wirklich immer ganz toll behalten stadt
garten leibniz zahnstein ja wirklich im museum für bildende künste gibt es eine class für den
mit dem angeblichen Zahnstrahlen des Universals gelernt.
Leibniz' Zahnstein.
Ich war immer lustig generiert, ja.
Langsam Rosti.
Vor allem, ja wirklich.
Und wirklich immer ganz toll bei Halluzinationen,
wenn das LLM ja wirklich hinter offensichtlichen Quatsch schreibt.
Wichtig ist auch nochmal zu erwähnen,
so ein klitzekleines Modell wie Qen 3.6 mit nur 27 Milliarden Parametern,
Das ist auch anfälliger für zum Beispiel Prompt Injection.
Also zum wiederholten Mal, nutzt das so komplett mit Vollzugriff nur auf Systemen, wo nichts Wichtiges drauf ist.
Kurzer Einschub, ja also besser mit Sprache umgehen.
Genau, extra, think extra, make no mistakes.
Stimmt.
In keinem Fall das lokale LLM Jammer 4 von Google.
Das habe ich in der Variante 26BA4B tatsächlich auf meiner brandneuen Steam-Maschine.
Ich finde übrigens die Benamung von komprimierten Model-Geschichten so geil.
Gamma 426BA4BITQATUDQ4XLGGUF.
Ja, obviously, natürlich, logisch, sofort, mir sagt jede Abkürzung was.
8 GB GPU-Speicher und 16 GB normalen RAM laufen lassen und von Hermes als Intelligenz nutzen lassen, das ging auch.
Guckt hier diese 3003-Animation, habe ich davon coden lassen, aber das hat nicht wirklich Spaß gemacht, weil das auf der Steam-Maschine wirklich extrem langsam läuft, eben weil das nicht komplett in die GPU passt und das immer wieder in den normalen RAM auslagern muss.
Einschub Ende, jetzt geht es wieder um Quen. Ich hoffe, ich habe euch nicht verwirrt, dass jetzt auf einmal von einem anderen Sprachmodell die Rede ist.
Wir sind nicht so schnell verwirrt, Chad, oder?
Ich wollte einmal zumindest Gemma 4 erwähnen, weil das auch ziemlich hyped gerade. Aber in Sachen Computerbedienung und Coding schneidet Quen 3.6, 7.7.
Chat, Chat, Chat.
Wie hieß dieses Ding nochmal?
Wir haben das letztens mal runtergeladen.
Ich habe es vergessen, wie das hieß.
Dieses Image-Generierung-Skui.
Wie hieß denn das nochmal?
Ach, Comfy UI.
Das hat er doch eben gezeigt, ne?
Comfy UI war das.
Stimmt's?
Ich glaube, das war das.
Habe ich das nicht sogar noch auf dem Desktop?
Ah ja, jedoch hier.
Comfy UI.
Ah ja.
Meines Erachtens besser ab.
Deshalb habe ich mich jetzt darauf fokussiert.
Und jetzt endlich, was braucht ihr, um das tolle Quen von Alibaba laufen zu lassen?
Also ich habe das auf drei Rechnern ausprobiert.
Auf dem Framework Desktop mit 128 GB Unified Speicher,
beim Gaming PC mit RTX 4090 und auf meinem MacBook Air M2 mit 24 GB Unified Speicher.
Bei MacBooks weiß ich es nicht genau, wie das da ist, aber wahrscheinlich auch.
Die eignen sich ja, also generell...
Die Apple-Hardware eignet sich ja richtig gut für lokale KI-Modelle.
Grafikrahmen und Systemrahmen und so, das hängt ja irgendwie alles zusammen.
Was aber irgendwie witzig ist, weil Apple hat wohl richtig gute Hardware, um lokale KI laufen zu lassen.
Aber die KI von Apple suckt.
Also Apple hat mit die beste Hardware quasi für lokale KI-Modelle, aber selbst keine
gescheite KI am Start.
Mir ist klar, dass das alles schon so Luxus-Hardware ist, die man nicht einfach irgendwo rumliegen
hat, aber 24 GB Speicher, die braucht man halt, damit man diese 17 GB Weight, also das
27 Milliarden Parameter Modell...
Ich muss grad mal was gucken.
Geiz halt.
Habe ich hier irgendwo Eier?
Guck mal, da ist...
Was kosten aktuell meine Grafikkarte?
Nochmal so, theoretisch.
Der hat keine Angebote.
Okay.
Historische Daten.
Also ich habe die hier so gekauft.
Dezember.
Also für 2000 Euro ungefähr habe ich die gekauft.
Hier so.
So in dem Dreh.
Und den letzten Preis im Januar war schon 3.400. Im Januar. Gucken wir mal, ob es irgendwelche lieferbaren 4090 gibt.
Boah
Das ist schon
Und es gibt schon eine 5090
dürfen wir nicht vergessen, ja
Und das gibt es nur auf
so einem komischen Ebay Shop
Nirgendwo
anders
Die gibt's auch gar nicht richtig lieferbar, oder?
So, gucken wir mal, was kostet aktuell eine 50, eine 50,90.
Puh.
Einfach das Doppelte.
Einfach mehr als das Doppelte, als ich damals 2022 bezahlt habe.
Oh ja.
Bam.
Okay, hier war die wahrscheinlich ganz neu.
Dann bam.
Jetzt wieder.
Es ist schon ordentlich teuer.
Hier mit plus Kontext, plus Puffer irgendwo laufen lassen kann.
Also am besten ist das extrem schneller Speicher, also GPU-Speicher
oder halt gemeinsamer GPU und CPU RAM, wie bei Apple Rechnern und zum Beispiel auch dem Framework Desktop.
Das Modell läuft auch auf 32 GB normalem DDR5 Speicher, aber das ist extrem lahm.
Wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt, hä, du hast doch gerade gesagt, 24 GB reichen aus.
Ja, aber wenn ihr insgesamt nur 24 GB habt, dann geht das eben nicht,
weil das Betriebssystem ja auch noch irgendwo hin muss.
GPU Speicher reichen 24 GB, das kann ja...
Video gerade ein bisschen geklitschert.
komplett exklusiv vom LLM verwendet werden. Zum Thema Geschwindigkeit gehen wir gleich noch ein
bisschen tiefer ins Rapid-Hole. Erstmal ganz kurz, wie man Hermes Quick & Dirty ausprobieren kann.
Betonung auf Quick & Dirty, das ist jetzt nicht der beste Weg, sondern ein einfacher. Und zwar
installiert ihr Ollama, das gibt's für Linux, macOS und Windows. Und wenn das installiert ist,
tippt ihr einfach Ollama auf der Kommandozeile ein und dann wählt ihr aus Launch Hermes Agent
Klammern Install.
Ach, das haben die mittlerweile schon eingebaut, oder was?
Und dann fragt Ulama, welchen Provider ihr nehmen wollt.
Okay, die geben sich ja wirklich Mühe, es einfach zu machen für die Leute.
Also welches LLM.
Und da will euch dann Ulama irgendwelche Cloud-Modelle verkaufen und ein Abo.
Aber das wollt ihr nicht, sondern ihr wählt dann zum Beispiel, wenn ihr den Speicher habt,
Quen 3.6 aus, gibt auch noch kleiner Modelle.
Damit wird Hermes nicht so gut laufen, aber könnt ihr auch ausprobieren.
Und dann wird Quen 3.6 auf eurem System runtergeladen.
Und dann könnt ihr Hermes direkt damit benutzen.
Dann seid ihr schon fertig.
Aber Ulama ist ziemlich sicher nicht die beste Variante, um lokales LLM laufen zu lassen.
Das hat ganz viele Gründe.
Aber wie ihr gerade gesehen habt, ist es extrem einfach.
Ab jetzt müsst ihr auch nicht mehr Ulama starten für Hermes.
Ihr könnt einfach Hermes eingeben.
Wenn ihr Hermes Model eingebt, könnt ihr auch einfach andere LLM-Provider nutzen.
Zum Beispiel, wie gesagt, meinen Rechner im Nebenraum mit RTX 4090.
Einfach die IP-Adresse eingeben.
Und da habe ich dann halt den Vorteil, dass Qen 3.6 komplett im schnellen Grafikspeicher läuft.
Und das ist, wie gesagt, wirklich sauschnell.
Das flutscht.
Sowohl bei der Tokenberechnung, also dem Generieren von Tokens, als auch beim sogenannten Pre-Processing.
Ich hatte ja am Anfang erklärt, dass diese Arganischen Systeme immer riesige Prompts ins Sprachmodell reinfüttern.
Ja, vor allem diese ganzen Reasoning-Prompts.
Und die müssen halt immer erstmal bearbeitet werden, bevor es losgehen kann mit den Antworten.
Und ich muss zugeben, dass ich in der Vergangenheit bei Tests von lokaler KI wirklich zu viel Fokus auf Token-Generierung gelegt habe, einfach weil ich nicht mit argentischen Systemen getestet habe.
Ich habe einfach nur mini-kurze Prompts ausprobiert, also sowas wie erzähl mir eine Geschichte und ja, da ist dann das Prompt-Processing unwichtig, weil das Prompt ja nur so kurz ist.
Ja, das ist in der Praxis nur die halbe Wahrheit, weil es bringt mir wenig, wenn mein System zwar in kurzer Zeit viele Tokens ausgeben kann, dafür aber vorher ewig auf dem Prompt rumkaut.
Deshalb ist Prompt Processing wichtig.
Guckt mal hier, das sind die Benchmark-Ergebnisse auf den drei Rechnern, die ich hier nutze.
PP-512 ist erwähntes Prompt Processing, also PP für Prompt Processing.
Und TG-128 ist Token Generation.
Beides ist angegeben in Token pro Sekunde.
Und ihr seht...
Warum ist das MacBook so schlecht?
Auf der RTX 4090 alles viel schneller als auf dem Framework Desktop und vor allem dem MacBook M2.
Allerdings knallt der Rechner mit RTX 4090 im LLM-Betrieb auch über 500 Watt weg.
Beim Framework sind es nur 140 Watt.
Ermittelt habe ich die Zahlen übrigens mit Lama Bench.
Das ist Teil von Lama CPP, der wohl zurzeit gebräuchlichsten LLM-Abzapf-Software-Bibliothek.
Olamer nutzt auch intern Lama CPP, will aber immer alles automatisch machen, was oft nicht das ist.
Konnte man bei Olamer nicht auch irgendwie sowas angeben?
Oh Lama prompt oder so und dann hat es dir die Tokens ausgegeben.
Das haben wir doch auch mal gemacht auf der NAS-Kiste, zu gucken wie schnell das ist.
Was richtig ist, zum Beispiel wollte es auf meiner RTX 4090 hier nicht komplett im GPU-Speicher laufen,
sondern teilweise auf der CPU, was es dann elend lahm gemacht hat.
Lama CPP ist etwas spröde in der Bedienung, aber wenn es erstmal läuft, dann läuft das.
Kleines Geständnis von meiner Seite, ich installiere Lama CPP eigentlich nicht mehr manuell, sondern nur noch per Coding Agent, also mit Cloud Code oder Codex.
Also will ich einen Rechner ernsthaft für lokale KI verwenden, dann gehe ich einmal kurz in die Cloud, wie gesagt mit Cloud Code oder Codex oder auch GLM 5.2 aus China, auch ein Modell, was gerade hypt und was damit gut funktioniert.
Das heißt, man benutzt ein Cloud Model, um seinen Rechner lokal zu setupen für lokale Models. Warum braucht man da ein Cloud Model für?
Und dann sage ich dem, er soll auf diesem Rechner mal überlegen, welches lokale Modell für argentische KI da am besten laufen könnte.
Und er soll dann Messreihen machen.
Zum Beispiel sage ich dann, benutze mal die Modelle QEN 3.6 und GAMMA 4 mit unterschiedlichen Quantisierungen.
Dann probiere ich auch gerne nochmal die unterschiedlichen Varianten aus.
denn Qen 3.6 und Gamma 4 gibt es einmal als sogenannte Dense-Varianten,
aber auch als Mixture of Experts-Version, MOE.
Bei MOE ist immer nur ein Teil der Parameter aktiv,
weshalb es meist deutlich schneller läuft,
aber dafür ist die Qualität auch ein bisschen schlechter.
Bei Dense-Modellen, da sind immer alle Parameter gleichzeitig aktiv.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich mit dem Dense-Modell, also dem...
Was, du hast deine RDP-Daten einfach in einem chinesischen Formen gepostet?
Scheiße.
Eine Public IP, wo du dich einladen konntest per ADP.
But why?
Wenn ihr 27b von QN36 bessere Erfahrungen gemacht habt, das Mixture of Experts Modell, das heißt QN3.635b, ich hab's euch gesagt, Rabbit Hole.
Das Ding ist leider auch noch, dass das lokale LLM nicht nur irgendwie laufen muss, sondern wenn ihr es mit Hermes Agent verwenden wollt, braucht ihr auch ein großes sogenanntes Kontextfenster von mindestens 65.000 Token.
Das ist wie gesagt so das Kurzzeitgedächtnis, also die Tokens, die das Ding im Gedächtnis, im Speicher behält.
Je größer der Kontext, desto mehr Speicher wird zusätzlich benötigt und desto langsamer wird es auch.
Deswegen, obwohl die Weights nur 17 GB groß sind, brauche ich trotzdem die 24 GB meiner Grafikkarte, wegen des großen Kontext.
Auf meinem MacBook Air M2 läuft QN36 mit 27B und 4-Bit-Quantisierung, übrigens maximal mit 16K Kontext.
Und das muss da dann auch schon ein bisschen was auf die SSD auslagern.
Also mit Hermes kann ich es vergessen auf meinem MacBook.
Wie gesagt, man braucht mindestens 64k Context für Hermes, aber damit Hermes wirklich Spaß macht, will man eigentlich sogar 100k oder im besten Fall genau 226.144 Tokens.
Das ist das Maximum, was Quen 3.6 beherrscht, weil auch schon bei kleineren agentischen Aufgaben und vor allem Programmierprojekten werdet ihr sehen, dass euer Context vollläuft und Hermes dann immer wieder...
Das Problem hatte ich auch, als ich das mal lokal ein bisschen ausprobiert habe.
komprimieren muss. Mit 200k Tokens,
da kriegt ihr viele Sachen komplett ohne
Kompression und neue Ansätze.
Und wie gesagt, Context...
Motorlearner, du meinst für neue Ideen für das
C++-Gremium, wie man die Sprache noch schlechter
machen könnte, oder wie?
Es kostet zusätzlich Speicher. Was ihr
deshalb machen könnt, wenn ihr mehr Context
haben wollt, den sogenannten KV-Cache
in den normalen RAM auslagern oder
auch den KV-Cache quantisieren,
also die Genauigkeit zu verringern.
Genauigkeit zu verringern, das klingt erstmal schlimm,
Klappt aber bis zu einem gewissen Grad nahezu verlustfrei. Sowieso quantisieren, ich habe ja in diesem Video schon häufiger von 4-Bit oder Q4 gesprochen, das bedeutet, dass statt 16-Bit-Gleitkommagenauigkeit die Parameter nur in 4-Bit-Genauigkeit gespeichert sind, was natürlich extrem viel Speicher spart und da kann man dann jetzt auch richtig drüber obsessen.
Es gibt nämlich nicht nur 4, 5, 6 Bit Quantisierung, sondern es gibt auch noch Hybrid Quantisierung, die unterschiedliche Layer unterschiedlich genau quantisieren.
Also Rabbit Hole.
Der Mainstream Konsens ist, dass Qen 3 627B meist in der Anthlos Variante...
Logitech. Warum?
Das ist die ganze Zeit schon auf 800 dpi gesetzt.
Warum ist es jetzt der Meinung...
Ah, die Maus ist auf 800 dpi.
UDQ4KXL.GGUF mit MTP verwendet wird.
Da passt das Ding nämlich nicht nur in 24 GB GPU-Speicher,
sondern da passt dann auch noch genug Kontext mit rein.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall die Variante, die ich die ganze Zeit verwendet habe.
Aber ey, da kann man sich richtig reinnerden.
Es gibt wirklich so viele unterschiedliche Varianten.
Es gibt auch unterschiedliche Leute, die die Modelle quantisieren und so.
Das ist halt das Ding, wenn die Sachen offen sind und man damit Sachen machen darf.
eigentlich gut dass das geht dann machen leute auch sache damit und das ist ja auch cool aber
es ist bisschen schwierig da den überblick zu behalten ich kann euch auf jeden fall sagen dass
ich hier meine besten erfahrungen mit diesem patrick vector of bull beste oder im lama cpp
aufruf gemacht habe das ist das besagte 27 b modell mit flash attention und mtp also multi
token prediction was die geschwindigkeit noch mal steigert und wenn ihr die multimodalen fähigkeiten
benutzen wollt, das heißt, wenn das Ding auch Bilder
erkennen soll. Das ist zum Teufel, das ist Multi-Token
Prediction. Das braucht ihr auch im Website
zu benutzen, weil das geht ja über Bilder.
Müsst ihr auch noch die MMPRUJ
Datei zusätzlich herunterladen?
Bei Hugging Face. Also, Chad.
Ich habe euch gefragt. Das ist ein komplexes
Thema. Wie gesagt, ich empfehle
den. Also, Chad, ich muss nicht sagen, ich sehe
für mich immer noch nicht, dass rein lokale
Models das alles ersetzen
können. Damals CPP, Kladderadatsch
mit einem Coding Cloud Tool
zu installieren. Ihr könnt dafür natürlich
auch Hermes mit einem lokalen Modell
verwenden. Habe ich auch ausprobiert. Das funktioniert
auch ganz gut, auch dass er diese Messreihen
macht und ausprobiert, was auf eurem System
am besten funktioniert. Aber da habt ihr halt
ein Henne-Ei-Problem. Auf dem
DLM benutze ich auch ganz gerne.
Zumindest in der Zeit, als es kostenlos
war. Das Neueste in
OpenCode. Wo ihr das lokale Modell
installieren wollt, kann ja nicht schon ein
lokales Modell laufen. Beziehungsweise
nur dann, wenn ihr wirklich extrem viel
Speicher habt. Ihr müsst aber dafür
auch nicht sofort einen Tropic oder
OpenAI-Abo abschließen. Zum Beispiel
mit OpenRouter könnt ihr
einige Cloud-Modelle auch komplett
kostenlos verwenden. Aber dann weißt du immer nicht, was...
Also das ist dann noch mehr shady.
Ich kenn das, ich hab das auch ausprobiert.
Und da bist du auch schnell an
Rate-Limits und so
gestoßen.
Ja, puh, ich hab selbst gemerkt...
Wenn du damit quasi Free-Models verwenden willst, die normalerweise
ordentlich was kosten.
Das hier am Ende doch noch ziemlich
komplex geworden. Und gerade bei den
Free Models, da weißt du halt auch
nicht genau, was der Anbieter mit dem Zeug natürlich
dann macht, was du da hinschickst.
Max, können wir das schauen? Moment.
Was?
Warum Tech-Firmen Bücher vernichten?
Machen sie das?
Das ist bestimmt was, wo ich mich aufregen muss, oder?
Aber, ey, ich find's halt auch nicht aufrichtig, wenn ich euch nur das Ergebnis zeige und nicht drauf eingehe.
Das ist wild. Okay, wenn der Chat sagt, dass es wild ist, dann gucken wir das jetzt.
Also, das ist fertig hier, das Video.
Es geht um...
Sind wir durch.
Wie man das selbst nachbaut.
Ich bin jedenfalls wirklich beeindruckt davon, wie brauchbar schon jetzt lokale Modelle mit Hermes sind.
Und GEN 3.6 und GEN 4 werden nicht die letzten lokal laufigen Modelle sein.
Das wird weiter besser werden. OpenAI und Entropic werden es in Zukunft nicht leicht haben, meine Prognose.
Das Ding ist nur, Hardware, auf der sowas läuft, bleibt teuer.
Aber alleine die Möglichkeit, auch interne, intime Daten zu verarbeiten, ohne Bedenken zu haben, dass die Daten sonst wohin abfließen,
also von den Prompt Injections mal abgesehen, das ist schon ein Goldwert.
Aber das muss ich auch nochmal betonen, sowas wie Can3Sex ist brauchbar, aber das ist auch noch fehleranfällig.
Und das ist auch noch nicht auf dem Niveau eines Entropic Cloud Fable oder so.
Das muss euch klar sein. Aber ich kann euch empfehlen, damit rumzuspielen.
Das ist extrem faszinierend.
Ja, das hatte ich bei OpenCode auch so, dass ich verschiedene Models hatte.
auf jeden fall gespannt cd 3003 in unser podcast 4004 machen um es jetzt sommerpause zwei sommer
gadgets was los ist wirklich okay also der chat sagt okay fünf minuten packen war okay sechs
minuten fünf minuten 59 ist quasi runden wir mal auf eine rätselhaftes verschwinden
um einflussreiche wirtschaftliche interessen aus dem ausland das ist sind quasi firmen die
Die ist ein unfassbar mächtig.
Und um einen bayerischen Schatz, der gerade unbemerkt entfernt wird.
Das finde ich ganz furchtbar, da kriege ich gleich Gänsehaut.
Helmut Martin aus Rosenheim ist es eigentlich nicht gewohnt, dass in seinem Antiquariat viele Bücher bestellt werden.
Ledergewunden hier.
Aber im Frühjahr...
Naja.
Antike Bücher von AI-Firmen aufgekauft.
Da verdient er wenigstens was.
schon Black Ops 2, ich hab keine PS5
und
ich glaube auch, dass das
heute nicht so geil ist, wie man es in Erinnerung hat.
Zumal ich eh die Vermutung habe, dass das
kompletter Cashgrab ist. Keines der Probleme, die das
Spiel jetzt hat, wird irgendwie wieder gefixt.
Also auch technische Probleme nicht. Die werden das wahrscheinlich nie wieder anfassen.
Passierte etwas,
das er so noch nie erlebt
hatte.
Vor etwa 4-5 Monaten kamen
einige Bestellungen.
Ein richtiger warmer Regen von Bestellungen in der Früh, als ich das Programm aufgemacht habe.
Sekunde Leute, ich muss mal den Browser wechseln.
Es geht um ein rätselhaftes Verschwinden.
Und alle von Zoom-Books aus Amerika, Illionois.
Und nicht nur Helmut Martin bekommt rätselhafte Bestellungen.
In München soll Bernhard Kitzinger plötzlich ebenfalls zahlreiche Bücher nach Übersee senden.
Soll ich dann eine Adresse schicken namens Zoom Books CEO Prepford an irgendein Nest in den USA.
Im Laufe der nächsten Wochen erleben Helmut Martin und Bernhard Kitzinger haargenau das Gleiche.
Erst die eher ungewöhnlichen Buchbestellungen aus Amerika.
Nicht eher ungewöhnlich, sondern noch nie dagewesen.
Dann plötzlich weitere Bestellungen, aber an eine andere Adresse.
Ein Kaff an der deutsch-polnisch-tschechischen Grenze.
Da kamen dann noch mal 30 Bestellungen,
aber komischerweise von Zumbugs Deutschland.
Und dann sind halt die Tuilerien gesprossen,
was mag dahinterstecken?
Schon Anfang des Jahres berichtete die Washington Post,
Der KI-Konzern Anthropic hatte seine KI
u.a. mit Millionen Büchern trainiert.
Und die neuesten Großbestellungen in Antiquariaten gab es weltweit.
Die Vermutung?
Buchhändler wie Zoom Books
kaufen über Online-Plattformen dort massenweise Bücher ein.
Die Bücher werden erst in ein Lager in Deutschland gebracht.
Und von da aus möglicherweise in die USA. Dort oder bereits in Europa könnten sie eingescannt und währenddessen oder anschließend zerstört werden.
Ja, okay, das ist schon ein bisschen schade um die Bücher, dass die dann zerstört werden.
Was machen die eigentlich, wenn sie die nochmal einscannen wollen? Pech gehabt.
Finde ich scheiße, wenn ich das jetzt so sagen darf.
Das tut schon weh, dass alte Bücher einfach entsorgt werden.
Es ist ein Stück Kultur, was weg ist und was dann unter Umständen von der KI auch entfremdet werden kann.
Wobei man halt auch sagen muss auf der anderen Seite, wenn diese Bücher jetzt halt nur im Regal stehen,
in dem Antiquariat und da vergammeln, hat auch keiner was von.
Um zu verstehen, was da möglicherweise passiert und was künstliche Intelligenz mit alten Büchern will,
hilft es, in ein Buch zu schauen.
Das kennt jeder.
Das ist ja die kleine Raupe.
Die einfach unglaublich viel frisst und immer größer und dicker wird.
Meinen die mich?
Doch satt war sie noch immer nicht, weil sie immer mehr essen musste. Das stimmt, ja.
Und die großen KI-Modelle, beobachten Experten, verhalten sich gerade genauso unersättlich.
Unersättlich nach Daten.
Dann wollen die mehr und die brauchen auch gerade dringend mehr.
Denn das Internet ist leer gefressen.
Ja vor allem, wo KIs ja wohl jetzt richtig Probleme kriegen ist, es gibt jetzt ja schon ein paar Jahre KIs und es gibt sehr viel KI-Content im Internet.
Das heißt die KI-Models trainieren mit dem Kram, die sie selbst verzapft haben.
3 verfügbare Texte dort, die von Menschen handgeschrieben wurden, sind der KI bereits bekannt.
Jetzt haben wir das Problem, jetzt haben die diesen massiven Berg...
Genau, Chat, KI-Inzucht könnte man das nennen, ja.
...Datenmenge quasi gehabt und jetzt suchen die ja, um besser zu werden, idealerweise...
KI-Ethikerin, Alter, was es nicht alles für Jobs gibt.
...noch mal mehr, weil sie ja nur über Menge groß geworden sind, nicht nur, aber hauptsächlich.
Und das geht ihnen halt aus.
Aber was in den bayerischen Antiquariaten so bestellt wurde, war doch selbst für eine KI etwas abseitig.
Zum Beispiel die Braunkohlenarchäologie im Rheinland, 500 Jahre Kesselbergstraße, also wirklich quer durch.
Kiefer-Otto-Bedie, Waldmünchen, Geschichte einer Stadt.
KI-Experten glauben aber, es ging weniger um die Sachinformationen, sondern mehr um etwas genuin Menschliches.
Die Sprache.
Nur wenigen anspruchsvollen Arten gelang der Weit die weitere Flucht in die balkanischen Gebirge, in die Berge des Pontus und Kaukasus.
Ein Großteil dieser wärmeliebenden Waldflöcher war zum Sterben verurteilt.
Bücher wurden gegengelesen. Bücher haben einen viel höheren Standard.
Und das heißt, die Firmen sind daran interessiert, die Bücher zu haben, weil die damit ihre Systeme trainieren können, die KI so trainieren können, dass die sinnvoll klingt.
Doch diesen sinnvoll klingenden Text hat eben einmal ein Mensch zu Papier gebracht.
In Europa darf KI deshalb nicht mit kopierten Büchern gefüttert werden.
Und wer soll das verhindern?
In den USA gilt, KI-Firmen dürfen Bücher nutzen, um künstliche Intelligenz zu füttern.
Um zu signalisieren, dass dem Autor dadurch kein finanzieller Schaden entsteht, vernichten sie sogar die Originale.
Juristisch gilt das als Fair Use.
Ich würde schon meinen, dass...
Hä? Wie Fair Use? Die haben die doch gekauft und bezahlt.
Da dann laufend Gelder fließen müssten.
Wenn Bücher zerstört werden, ist es nicht fair.
Zoom Books schreibt, die Firma selbst scanne und zerstöre keine Bücher.
Die KI-Firmen haben uns nicht geantwortet.
Achso.
Ob...
Ja gut, aber da gibt es ja kein Copyright in dem Sinne mehr drauf, wenn die Dinger uralt sind.
Künstliche Intelligenz am Ende auch ein wunderschöner Schmetterling sein wird?
Wir werden die Verpuppung beobachten.
Gadgets lohnt sich wirklich. Eiswürfel.
Eiswürfel sind sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
KI-Ventilator.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Das ist mir egal.
So kompliziert war
der Internetzugang WDR...
1999! Alter!
Haben wir das nicht schon mal geguckt?
By the way, der macht das heute immer noch, der Typ, ne?
Ich glaube, der hat einen eigenen Channel mittlerweile.
Der macht das mit seinem Sohn zusammen, glaube ich.
Ey, lange Videos.
geht. Ich muss spätestens
eine halbe Stunde was essen. Ich habe ein brutales
Hunger.
Schauen wir mal, welche Sommer-Gadgets
was ist das denn?
Passwort-Manager-Tierlist. Okay.
Das habe ich hier schon oft. Das skippen
wir jetzt mal.
Ein bisschen durch.
Ich sage euch mal meine
Passwort-Manager-Tierlist. Okay, was hat er denn hier unten
drin? Lass mal kurz gucken.
Was hat er denn hier unten drin?
Das ist die Apple
Passwort-App, oder?
Das ist Bitwarden, Voltwarden.
Das ist Keypass.
Das ist NordVPN Pass oder wie das heißt.
One Password, das habe ich nie verwendet.
Wo ich auch nicht verstehen konnte, dass die Leute...
Ich verstehe es ja immer noch nicht, warum die Leute den ganzen Krempel in die Cloud packen.
The List, okay.
Wir gucken das jetzt nicht ganz, ich skip das ein bisschen.
Ich will einfach nur gucken, was es zur Auswahl gibt.
Wisst ihr, das ist auch so ein Ding, das würde ich immer mal in Frage stellen.
Es sagen ja auch viele Anbieter, ja, es wird ja lokal verschlüsselt und wir können das selbst nicht entschlüsseln.
Okay, das mag zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt technisch so sein.
Wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, dass das auch alles ordentlich implementiert ist,
also nicht, dass die irgendwelche Libraries verwenden mit Schwachstellen oder Algorithmen verwenden mit Schwachstellen.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, das ist aktuell so.
Das wird mit einem kleinseitigen Key verschlüsselt, den der Anbieter zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht kennt.
So, aber wer sagt denn, dass übernächste App-Version, das immer noch so ist, übernächste App-Version schickt die App einfach den privaten Key an den Hersteller und wer soll es merken? Merkt keiner. Ganz normales Update über den App-Store.
und dass das gar nicht so weit hergeholt ist,
dass Apps von heute auf morgen kaputt gehen.
Ich hatte mal eine App für OTP-Generierung,
nämlich die hier.
Und die wurde dann irgendwann verkauft.
Ich hatte dort ein paar OTP,
also ein paar, wie nennt man das,
zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung-Sachen drin.
Und dann hat der Typ, dem die App ursprünglich gehört hat,
hat die App verkauft.
Und von heute auf den anderen Tag
hatte ich keine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
mehr, weil sie eine Paywall
vorgeschoben haben.
Pech gehabt.
Und Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung,
Sachen speichern, ist genauso
wichtig, wie seine Passwörter
irgendwo speichern,
oder zumindest restauren können.
Ja?
Weil ihr lockt euch ja damit auch aus.
war einfach weg, sondern dann sieht man,
ganz so unwahrscheinlich ist das
nicht, selbst wenn es heute so
ist, dass das alles super safe
und auditiert von
Leuten, denen ihr traut ist und sonst was,
das kann in der nächsten
App-Version, die verkaufen die App, ihr
bekommt das nicht mit, ich mein, guck mal,
ich hab hier auf meinem Handy wahrscheinlich
acht Seiten oder sowas Apps
drauf mittlerweile, ne, also
So, warte, was habe ich hier?
Ich habe eine Seite, zwei Seiten, drei Seiten.
So, und dann habe ich noch Ordner.
Ordner mit irgendwie teilweise fünf Unterdingern.
Also ich habe bestimmt, wenn ich es verteilen würde,
habe ich sechs Seiten Apps oder so auf dem Handy.
Und wer bitteschön verfolgt die Entwicklung von sechs Seiten Apps?
Das sind, lass mal gucken, wie viele Apps sind das?
Ich zähle das mal.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs.
1, 2, 3, 4, also 24 Apps pro Seite.
24 mal 6, 144.
Wer verfolgt die Entwicklung von 144 Apps?
Ob sich da irgendwie der Hersteller geändert hat,
ob der noch vertrauenswürdig ist und bla und sonst was.
Dazu kommt,
Finn, gut, dass du
sagst, ich wollte gerade was ähnliches
sagen, zwar jetzt nicht mit
GitHub, dazu kommt,
dass in letzter Zeit
auch schon Updates
verteilt wurden, ich rede
jetzt mal nicht unbedingt von Handy-Apps,
da fällt mir jetzt kein Beispiel ein,
aber ich könnte wetten, dass es da auch so ist.
Zumindest guckt euch beispielsweise
Notepad++ an.
Notepad++, sehr beliebtes Tool für Windows, hatte manipulierte Updates auf dem offiziellen Server.
Und ganz ehrlich, so anfällig wie das alles mittlerweile ist und so viele Supply, was der Finn gerade im Chat sagt, so viele Supply Chain Angriffe wie es aktuell gibt.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile nicht nur bei NPM, die Dinge haben sich ja auch schon in, wo war das letztens, in Java Pakete und in Python Packages eingeschlichen.
und da könnte es durchaus sein, dass der Entwickler
gar nichts Böses will, aber
seine App trotzdem verseucht ist,
weil die mit irgendeinem manipulierten
NPM-Paket gebaut wurde.
Also das kann man nicht sagen.
Du kannst es nicht ausschließen,
nur weil das super
toll auditiert ist. Unser nächstes Update
kann das schon wieder alles anders sein.
Das kann mit
KeyPass auch passieren, klar.
Klar kann das mit KeyPass passieren.
Natürlich kann das passieren.
Aber du siehst halt,
dass du, du kannst dich dagegen halt nicht wehren.
Und ein Cloud-Anbieter,
der dann auf einmal deinen Key
sich schickt,
weil der neue Besitzer der App
meint, ey,
wir wollen das jetzt,
ist halt die Frage, traust du denen?
Traust du denen, dass das nicht passiert?
Also ich traue Keypasta
tatsächlich mehr zu.
aus mehreren Gründen.
Erstens kann ich es theoretisch selbst bilden.
Ich kann mir das von GitHub runterladen.
Ich kann sogar kontrollieren, dass der Build-Output
den gleichen Hash ergibt, wie das, was ich installiere.
Oder ich abdecke
einfach mein KeePass eine Weile nicht.
Solange es da keine großen Probleme
gibt, kann ich das auch machen.
Also die Chancen sind deutlich geringer.
Ja, hundertprozentig sicher
bist du nirgendwo.
das ist halt so ein Ding.
Und gerade bei Anbietern, also das war jetzt
ja eines von zwei Sachen.
Das erste ist, der Anbieter macht das
mutwillig.
Und das zweite ist, es passiert aus Versehen.
Das zweite kann bei jeder Software passieren,
die du updatest und nicht kontrolliert hast.
Aber das erste, der Anbieter
macht das mutwillig.
Das ist bei Apps aus dem App Store
ein realistisches Risiko.
Wie ich euch ja gerade gezeigt habe.
Ich meine, guck dir mal.
hier.
Das, was ich euch hier gerade gezeigt habe.
Die, äh, hier.
Die App. Die haben von heute auf morgen
eine Paywall eingeführt
und ich konnte nicht mehr auf meine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
Sachen zugreifen. Gut.
Der hätte das genauso gut
an irgendein China-Chinesen-Ding verkaufen
können, die einfach jetzt
sagen, ey,
wir schicken einfach mal
deine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
Shared Secrets nach China.
und schon wäre zumindest eine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung,
bis das jemand merkt,
hätte wahrscheinlich auch eine ganze Weile gedauert,
und schon hätte es zumindest mal den zweiten Faktor ausgehebelt.
Also das kann, das ist nicht so weit hergeholt,
dass das mutwillig bei einem Anbieterwechsel passiert,
oder passieren kann.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie ich das da wieder hingebogen habe?
Das habe ich, glaube ich, schon mal erzählt.
Folgendermaßen,
Ich hab die App
Downgradet
Wisst ihr eigentlich
Was für ein krasser Act das ist
Eine App zu downgraden
Auf IOS
Das ist ja offiziell geht das ja nicht
Find ich auch geil
Recycle
Habt ihr jemand von euch schon mal
eine App downgraded auf iOS?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, weil das übelste Abfuck ist.
Also offiziell sagt Apple, das geht nicht.
Früher konnte man wohl in iTunes
noch Versionen auswählen, aber mittlerweile das geht nicht mehr.
So, was ich dann machen musste, war
folgendes.
Ich zeige euch mal. Das ist wirklich
Wissenschaft
für sich.
Ja, Geit.
das hier, diesen Guide, glaube ich,
dass es der war, dem habe ich
gefolgt.
Das ist wirklich ein Riesenakt.
Du musst dir
eine alte iTunes-Version installieren,
dass es funktioniert.
Dann habe ich mir eine Windows-VM installiert.
Dann habe ich mir so ein
Man-in-the-Middle-Proxy installiert.
iTunes installiert, eingeloggt.
Dann musst du
da musst du irgendwie die Bildnummer von deiner App raussuchen
dann musst du
Root-Zertifikate installieren vom Proxy
dann musst du den Request überwachen
der
zu Apple geht
wenn der Request gesendet wird über den Proxy
von iTunes
ja iTunes sendet ein Request
der Request wird intercepted vom Proxy
setzt ein Breakpoint
und dann
musst du in dem
Payload
Breakpoint, ja, dann musst du
in dem Payload das
anklicken
und hier irgendwo
editieren
ja, ok Breakpoints
get the old version
install it, genau, du musst dann quasi
ein Breakpoint setzen im Proxy und dann
dort die alte Version eintragen,
dass du manipulierst quasi den
Request, den es zu iTunes,
den iTunes zu Apple schickt.
Sodass iTunes quasi
denkt, es lädt die App runter, aber es
lädt eine alte Version von der App runter.
Genau, hier musst du
die Sache, also du interceptest
quasi den Request an
Apple und manipulierst den.
Und dann lädt iTunes das
runter, dann ziehst du dir das
IPA und
das kannst du dann hiermit aufs Handy installieren.
Alter!
WTF? Da habe ich bestimmt drei Stunden Gebrauch,
bis ich den Scheiß downgraded hatte.
Mittlerweile verwende ich
Ente...
Ente-Auth
für
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Auch komplett Open Source. Könnte damit
morgen theoretisch auch passieren.
Aber ich back up das Lokal.
Encrypted.
mittlerweile
meine 2FA
Tokens.
Das benutze ich mittlerweile.
Ah, schön, dass du da bist.
Ich weiß, ich habe schon eine Weile kein Video mehr auf YouTube
gemacht, aber es wird demnächst wieder ein YouTube-Video
geben.
Kann man Microsoft Authenticator
migrieren? Ne, klar kannst du nicht
du kriegst aus dem
Microsoft Authenticator das Shared Secret nicht raus
es könnte sein, eventuell
da bin ich mir nicht sicher, dass
du, aber ich glaube, ne, ne, ne
doch bin ich mir sicher
Microsoft Authenticator
hat keinen Export
nur ein Backup in die Cloud und da
kommst du wahrscheinlich nicht dran
Battlefield mit dem Friseur
Friseur habe ich gestern
gerade im Discord mal wieder angeschrieben
hat es bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen, aber wir spielen
bestimmt kein Battlefield
gucken was der gerade so treibt
ja, also ihr seht
komplett straight forward, so eine App zu
downgraden auf IOS, riesen Akt
ja und nur
warum? weil der seine App
verkauft hat an irgendwelche China-Chinesen
oder keine Ahnung wohin. Und die eine
Paywall davor gepackt haben.
Schon ziemlicher
Kack, oder?
Und das war wirklich, das war echt
ein Riesenakt, bis ich das
hier auf die Reihe gekriegt hab.
Bis das alles funktioniert hat.
Übrigens, jetzt wo ich grad IPA gesehen hab,
IPA gesehen hab,
Auf der Arbeit müssen wir auch regelmäßig iOS-Applications runterladen von einem Anbieter, das ist ganz furchtbar wirb.
Das ist ein Anbieter, der benutzt eine Container-Registry, um Binaries zu speichern.
Da gibt es so ein Tool, da kann man quasi in Docker-Container-Registries,
kann man nicht nur Images speichern, sondern man kann quasi ein Container-Image hochladen mit Binaries drin,
was dann wieder extrahiert wird.
Das wirst du System iOS-Applikationen zu distributen, das ich je gesehen habe.
Da brauchst du auch so ein Spezial-Tool, dass du das downloaden kannst.
Super durch die Brust ins Auge.
Es gab bestimmt viele Opfer, die gezahlt haben.
Das Schlimme ist, dass ich gelesen habe, weiß ich nicht, ob das stimmt,
dass ich gelesen habe, selbst Leute, die das bezahlt haben, die Paywall,
dass sie nicht mehr zugreifen konnten auf ihre Passwörter.
Auf ihre 2FAs.
Wie teuer war das? Gar nichts, das ist kostenlos.
Oder was meinst du?
Meinst du, die Container Registry oder...
Achso, die Paywall.
Weiß ich nicht, gucken wir doch mal.
Gucken wir mal.
Schauen wir mal.
Donaten.
Okay.
Ich...
Licensing?
Ich glaube,
die haben da einfach ganz schnell
wieder...
Ich glaube, die haben da einfach ganz schnell
wieder zurückgedreht danach.
Die haben seitdem auch nicht mehr updated hier.
Ich glaube, das gibt es nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, die sind weg.
Ich habe die App damals direkt wieder geschlossen und gleich geguckt, wie man das downgraden kann.
Zum Glück hat da irgendjemand so einen Guide geschrieben.
Stellt euch mal vor, ich hätte selbst rausfinden müssen.
Da habe ich tagelang dran gesessen.
Das wäre richtig reudig gewesen.
Oh, Sekunde. Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat.
Moment, Moment. Ich muss checken, was die Mikrowelle macht.
Moment, Moment.
Mein Home Assistant lädt gerade nicht.
Was ist da los?
Home Assistant.
Hallo, Home Assistant.
Warum lädt das nicht?
Was ist da los?
Zuletzt aktualisiert vor 18 Stunden.
Das kann ja nicht sein.
Home Assistant hat keinen Bock.
Home Assistant.
Alter.
Sag mal.
Hängt mein...
Hängt mein Nass oder so?
Was ist da los?
Jo.
Ich mach da einfach nix.
Geil.
Ich glaub mein Home Assistant ist kaputt, Leute.
Da könnte man das sagen, das suckt ganz schön.
Tja.
Dann weiß ich nicht, was die Mikrowelle macht.
Ach, guck mal, der macht auch Ukraine-Werbung.
Komm, wir supporten ihn mal ein bisschen.
Moment, es ist wieder was Neues.
Alter, wie viele Nasus haben die bitteschön?
DXP 4800, DXP 4800 Pro, DXP 4800 GT?
What the fuck?
Hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Okay, was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen dem GT und der Pro?
2x 10 Gig oder was?
Gibt es da irgendwelche Vergleiche dazwischen?
Nee, natürlich nicht
Das wäre auch zu einfach
Jeden Streamer neu ist nass
So, lass mal gucken
Vielleicht ist das jetzt ja
Oh, ein PCI-Express-Slot oder sowas
8GB RAM?
Was ist das für eine CPU?
Ah, hier
vier kerne 8 ok das ist noch weniger leistungs das ist weniger leistungsfähig wie das vermutlich
wobei weiß ich nicht schwer zu sagen das eine ist eine low power intel cpu mit zwar sechs kern
aber das ist ein schnellerer amd cpu mit vier kern dafür 8 threads und die intel cpu kann glaube ich
kein Hyper-Threading auf
4 von 6 Kernen.
Weiß ich nicht. Schwer zu sagen, was da schneller ist.
Aber
was ist denn da jetzt der
größte Unterschied dazwischen?
Das muss ich mir
jetzt gerade mal angucken.
Leute, ich hab mein...
Oh Gott. Ah, ich hab
zu viele...
Zu viele
Tabs, Leute.
habt ihr schon was?
Compare.
Okay, sehr gut.
Excellent. Danke, Chat.
Ihr seid sehr high IQ wieder.
Excellent. So.
10. Also
10 Gig.
Und das hat 2,5 Gig
und 10 Gig. Ah ja.
Ah, lasst mal kurz gucken.
Was hat denn das überhaupt für eine Netzwerkkarte?
Was hat das für eine Netzwerkkarte?
Ich hoffe, das hat auch nicht diese schrottige
Realtek-Netzwerkkarte drin.
Scroll Champ.
Ja, ähm.
Was ist denn da für eine Netzwerkkarte drin?
Das sagen sie wieder nicht.
Ist das eine Realtek?
Was ist da für eine Netzwerkkarte drin?
Das müssen wir jetzt mal rauskriegen.
Specs.
Wolltest du nicht mal deine Klimaanlage in der H1 binden?
Doch, hatte ich jetzt schon mehrfach verschiedene Wege.
Aber, ja.
Ach, guck mal, hier.
Raspberry Pi Cloud.
Ja, was ist es denn für eine Netzwerkkarte?
Hat er da was drüber?
Okay, gut, gut.
Das ist nicht die schrottige Realtek-Netzwerkkarte.
Okay.
Die gehen.
Die gehen klar.
Ja.
Gut, ich kaufe mir trotzdem kein neues NAS.
Genau, was?
Chat, ich bin mir halt echt unschlüssig, was besser ist, ja?
Das ist ein Intel Pentium Gold 8500.
Das sind...
Moment, hier, da muss ich gucken.
Muss ich gucken.
Das ist ein... hier, der da.
Das sind zwei Performance Cores und vier Efficiency Cores.
die Kurs.
8 Threads. Okay, passt.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich würde sagen,
nimmt sich jetzt
nicht so viel.
Gucken wir mal. Versus.
Auch diese Seite.
Was? Keine Ahnung.
Was ist?
Was ist das hier für eine bescheuerte Seite, Alter?
Das ist ja mal null aussagekräftig.
Gibt es da irgendwas, wo man das...
Okay.
Also ich würde mal
ungefähr sagen, dass das
ungefähr
dass die
ungefähr gleich schnell sind, würde ich mal
einfach drauf tippen
Weil das wurde noch nicht getestet
Oder doch? Oder what? Hä?
Also mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir, die Dinger sind ungefähr gleich schnell.
Ah, wie sieht es mit AES und so aus?
Yes, yes, okay.
Okay, die Dinger sind ziemlich, sind ziemlich.
Ach, das ist die GPU.
Okay, whatever.
Aber ich würde sagen, so ein großer Unterschied dürfte es nicht sein zwischen den CPUs.
sind jetzt also quasi gar nicht beide sind jetzt nicht die geilsten cpu ist du hattest
in dem 3003 video gefragt wieso man das setup in hermes mit einem local model
macht und es dann local nutzt mit einem cloud model macht ist
ja aber warum weil ich frage ist warum man das installieren nicht einfach selbst macht
warum er dazu Model braucht.
Der Unterschied ist schon da.
Ja.
Das stimmt.
Also ist
die CPU sogar schneller?
Das heißt,
das NAS, was ich hier
habe von denen, das Pro,
ist sogar leistungsfähiger als das
GT-NAS.
er hat auch mehr leistungsaufnahme leistungsaufnahme interessiert mich
überhaupt nicht das ding eilt zu 99 prozent rum
ok
dann keine ccc brauche ich jener ccc rahmen ist viel zu teuer und auch das u2
kann oder nicht
Oh.
Ist egal.
Ich würde am liebsten
eh das Minis-Forum nass nehmen.
Wenn die den Kram mit ihrer Netzwerkkarte
auf die Reihe kriegen.
Wollen wir mal bei Minis-Forum gucken, ob es da...
Minis, das, das, N5 Luft, genau.
Bioinformatiker.
Ein ehemaliger Azubi von mir hat Bioinformatik studiert.
Fällt mir da gerade so ein.
Bios Updates.
Support.
Haben die das hier unten irgendwo stehen?
Support vielleicht so?
Bam, bam, bam, bam.
Ich will mal gucken, ob es ein Bios Update vielleicht gibt.
Driver, Downloads.
Mini-PCs, Others,
NAS, Stels,
N5, N5R,
Driver Download,
Specs,
ne, gibt's nicht.
Die haben generell keine BIOS-Downloads, ne?
Also das muss man wirklich sagen,
der,
der Support von Minisforum ist wirklich
unterirdisch schlecht.
Es gibt einen neuen Driver für,
ach, gibt es,
Naja, das ist für Windows.
Wir müssen mal bei Realtek gucken,
ob es da wirklich einen neuen gibt mittlerweile.
Ah, hier gibt es
BIOS-Downloads. Dafür gibt es keine.
Weil das Max, das hatte doch.
Es gab doch
ein BIOS-Update für das N5 Max.
Ne, für das N5 Pro
gab es ein BIOS-Update. Hier ein BIOS.
Okay, für die andere nicht.
Und es gibt jetzt nochmal ein neues N5-Mac.
Also Minisforum haut...
Okay, der Button geht wieder nicht. Geil.
Oder whatever.
Die hauen...
Also das muss man echt sagen.
Die Minisforum-Leute hauen immer neue Hardware raus.
Ohne Sinn und Verstand.
Man kann jetzt hier noch mehr reinpacken.
Was für eine CPU ist drin?
Ryzen AI Max Plus 395.
Was ist das jetzt schon wieder für ein Ding?
Kerne
Das haut aber rein, das Ding
Dürfte ja ein bisschen mehr Strom verbrauchen
Okay, gucken wir mal
Realtek
Ja, genau
Realtek-Treiber.
Ah, gucke mal da.
Vom dritten, siebten.
Chat, ich würde sagen,
es wird mal wieder Zeit.
Nas, neuer Realtek-Treiber
testen.
Ich glaube, es wird mal wieder Zeit.
Haben die da... Moment, hatte
Realtek da sowas wie einen Change-Log?
Moment mal, es gab doch von Realtek
den Treiber.
Wir hatten doch auf GitHub
Okay, OpenWrt.
Vor neun Monaten, ja, okay.
Hier, hier, hier. Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wartet mal.
Ähm.
Git-Commits hatten wir da nicht, ne?
Downloads.
mkdr rtl 8127
und zip
ah ne das ist bzip
alter wie zum teufel
ein zip an ein bzip
bzip
gibt es
banzip oder so
ah gibt es sehr gut
einfach geraten
und jetzt ta
Moment, Z ist falsch.
Okay.
Was ist denn Act?
Ist in der Readme vielleicht ein Change Log oder sowas drin?
Nee, oder?
Change Log hat Real Tech anscheinend irgendwie nicht für Treiber.
Guck mal.
Real Tech, Treiber, Change Log.
Gibt's nicht.
Er soll nicht mehr jetzt den Diff vom Source Code angucken oder was?
Ist das euer Ernst, Realtek, ja?
Das ist natürlich auch kein Git-Repo, logisch, ne?
Ich kann mir doch jetzt nicht den Source Code diffen zwischen den zwei Treiberversionen,
um rauszukriegen, was sich da geändert hat.
Okay, das sieht immer noch so aus wie vorher.
Ja, ich kann schon.
Aber ich will nicht.
Also jetzt schon mal gar nicht.
Hört der halt
ein LLM damit.
Dazu bräuchte ich erstmal die alte Version nochmal.
Die gibt's...
Die gibt's irgendwo auf...
GitHub bestimmt.
Ah, hier guck mal,
die China-Chinesen.
Nice.
Hat der auch die älteren Versionen drinne?
Die 15er brauche ich.
Ja.
Proxmox läuft da drauf.
Guck mal, das ist hier die
15er.
Das ist die Vorgängerversion.
Dann klonen wir uns das hier gerade mal.
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
So, geht Clone hier rein.
So und jetzt haben wir hier RTL.
Hier ist das Source Code und da ist das Source Code.
Das ist mehr oder weniger der gleiche Krempel.
Okay, diff.
Alter.
Das wird jetzt richtig eklig.
Das kann ich nicht.
Wie viele Zeilen haben wir hier eigentlich?
Nee, das gucke ich jetzt nicht durch.
Ich gucke garantiert keine
3577 Zeilen durch.
Zumal von Source Code, den ich nicht verstehe.
Irgendein Treiber-Source Code,
Alter.
Und das meiste davon
ist Binary Magic.
Real Tech.
Realtek, warum macht ihr nicht einfach einen fucking Change-Log?
Warum gibt es nicht einfach einen Change-Log?
Okay, wir gucken mal was.
Kernel.
Wo war diese Seite, wo man Kernel-Komits ordentlich durchsuchen konnte?
Ich meine, wir können auch hier reingehen.
Repos.
Linux.
Das dauert jetzt ein bisschen.
Im Kernel ist nichts Neues.
Woher weißt du das?
Hast du selbst schon gesucht, oder was?
Oh, ich glaube, Kernel Pullen macht gerade nicht so ganz...
Kannst du nicht einfach in den Comet schauen?
Ja, doch, kann ich.
Also, nee, kann ich nicht.
Das sind keine Comets vom Hersteller.
Das sind Leute, die den Source Code vom Hersteller
einfach bei sich eingecheckt haben. Die wissen ja auch nicht,
was da passiert ist.
Warum geht das nicht?
Okay, whatever.
Ach, du hast vorgestern geschaut.
Im Kernel ist nichts neu.
Okay, shit.
Sag mal.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es geht top-down oder so?
Okay, also, Leute, es...
Ich lösche das jetzt einfach mal.
Und, boah.
Das dauert jetzt ein bisschen.
Und ich geht klonen mit den Linux-Körnern.
Es gab doch so eine Seite, da konnte man den Linux-Körner ordentlich durchsuchen.
Search, commits.
Da gab es doch so eine... Ich habe vergessen, wie das...
Das da?
Könnte das die Seite gewesen sein?
8127.
Ja.
Okay, das letzte ist vom April.
Warte.
2017.
Ach nee, die Dinger hießen im Kernel doch anders.
8189 oder so, gell?
Irgendwie so.
2016, ey.
Die hießen doch anders.
driver lockups geil klingt ja klingt ja ganz furchtbar vertrauenserweckend
ich weiß nicht mehr wieder wieder köln hieß linux linux r 81 69 so rum
alles so
ich check's nicht mehr keine ahnung
Ist auch wurscht.
Der hat auch nicht geupdatet.
Wir installieren das Ding einfach mal auf dem Nass und gucken, ob die Performance dann besser ist.
Also wir hatten ja mehrere Probleme damals.
und das erste Problem war, dass in
4Ms, also mit dem
offiziellen Treiber aus dem Linux-Körner,
war die Performance
in 4Ms unterirdisch
schlecht. Beim Senden
glaube ich, beim Senden haben wir quasi nur die
Hälfte von 10 Gig bekommen,
was halt ganz klar nach irgendeinem Bug aussieht.
Wenn wir den offiziellen Treiber
von Realtek installiert haben,
war das schneller, aber wir hatten ziemliche
Schwankungen.
Ja.
Oder könnte halt noch ein bisschen schneller sein.
Gucken wir mal.
So, Chat.
Jetzt gehe ich was essen.
Jetzt habe ich mega Hunger.
Vielleicht, vielleicht.
Ich verspreche aber nichts.
Weil ich muss jetzt was essen und dann noch eine Runde rennen gehen.
Vielleicht machen wir mit Z-Servers weiter heute Abend.
Weil wir haben ja noch genug
Aufgaben offen.
und vor allem noch genug schwere Aufgaben offen,
wo ich mich ein bisschen mit quälen kann.
Aber ihr habt es geschafft gestern, ne?
Sieben Prime Subs und wir haben die schwere Aufgabe gemacht.
Man muss sagen, die schwere Aufgabe ging eigentlich klar, oder?
Die wir gestern gemacht haben, für alle, die dabei waren.
Also die letzte schwere Aufgabe, die wir da gemacht haben
mit dem Docker Compose und dem InitDB,
die ging doch eigentlich klar, die war gar nicht so wild.
Du musstest dich eigentlich nur an den Fehlermeldungen lang hangeln.
Unter der Woche.
Ich kann nicht unter der Woche gescheit streamen.
Der einzige Tag, wo ich streamen kann, ist theoretisch Montag.
Das letzte, was wir gemacht haben gestern,
mit dem InitDB und so, das war tatsächlich eine schwere Aufgabe.
InitDB Postgres.
Wo wir das Datum zurückgestellt haben.
ach so abends ja gut abends renne ich eine runde und da bin ich eigentlich
kaputt weiß ich nicht ob ich das oder der woche hinkriegt wahrscheinlich eher
nicht
kreise client ja dazu fehlt mir dazu fehlt mir halt das karriere kreis hat
mindset das high performer klein set mindset
neuen zoll gebühren für china habe ich gelesen ja zahlt jetzt für jede ware
oder so
aber wahrscheinlich ist es trotzdem billiger dazu bestellen bestell ich mir
einfach mehr in china waren gruppe ja stelle ich mir halt bestelle ich mir
halt an Schatz 3 ESP32
bestelle ich mir mal 20.
Easy. Brauche ich zwar nicht, aber
wenn schon, denn schon.
Ne, das meine ich nicht.
Weiß. Das meine ich nicht.
Außerdem ist das
noch der von April.
Meinst du, wie das offizielle
Kernel-Modul heißt, was die
Netzwerkkarte unterstützt?
Was im Kernel ist.
Jeden Morgen um 5 Uhr Rennen gehen. Ja, das wäre das
High-Performer-Grindset-Mindset.
da müsste aber in die gruppe kommen vorher
das war ich nicht ich bin bis 37 dann fahre ich nach frankfurt auf die arbeit dann schaffe ich
was dann gehe ich ordentlich große portion mittagessen essen schaffe ich ein bisschen
was dann fahre ich heim dann gehe ich meine runde rennen oder fahrradfahren oder rennen
und Fahrrad fahren oder demnächst
rennen, schwimmen, rennen.
Und dann gucke ich ein bisschen
Stream, gepen.
Alles klar, Leute.
Ich habe mega Hunger.
Wir sehen uns vielleicht heute Abend. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.